you just showed up like you might need
some practice uh you going down for the
count it's going down tonight I do it
all for my family you do
[Music]
[Applause]
I have quite the crew here for Tommy
Fury versus Jake Paul to my left is the
Golden Boy 2.0 he has the biggest fight
of his life coming up Javonte tank Davis
it is The Undefeated Ryan Garcia
right now you're looking at me just
kidding me okay do you have a thing you
do when people say you're like you just
digital air Punch Yeah it's just one
fist up and when there's like hey let's
get a picture do you have a song that
what is the song you come out with your
walk out usually it's Superstar by Lupe
Fiasco oh that's a good song you are
would you say you are you know yeah yeah
you like to have a message in the intro
right kind of yeah for sure yeah yeah
mine would be Color Me bads I want to
sex you up you know what oh that way
they're the guys yep well let me finish
with an intro for sure I thought we were
going in yeah he wants to Color Me Bad
intro is uh I wish we could play right
now is Adam Ray you're I mean the the
dude is all over you're on Tom and Pammy
right you're on freaking uh uh was it
young Rock you're on freaking uh your
podcast about last night you're all over
but a lot going on man
um crush it last night at the Ice House
ice house is fun yeah the new look is
back we'll get to it it's back yeah and
then the gentleman over there he's the
richest man in the room most successful
person I know he's been famous since
I've been alive and I was introduced to
him from it's still one of my favorite
movies little monsters now my son
watches it he loves it he's on America
God's Talent he's America's Got Talent
yeah I don't know if that's how you say
that yeah we'll cut that out welcome to
America's Got Talent it's America's Got
Talent
is not one of them
you don't want me to be on there or
Jeopardy you don't want to be in there
that's Howie yeah thank you for doing
this my man you took it early I would
have I did I was in uh I I just posted
on my story I said I was in Dubai and
you called and said hey do you want to
watch the fight I was supposed to be
there another day so I flew in because I
wanna
you flew back from Dubai to see this
just just to do this oh all right
isn't a fight in goodbye yeah yeah right
yeah she'd rather be here
that's true friendship yeah that's it
it's also Calabasas
the Dubai of Southern California yes
Adam last night Ice House my man it's
back ice house is back back with
vengeance yeah it's uh they re-uh the
Lakers more or less bought it right and
did a little makeover on it
um you know it's definitely different
it's different there's like a like a
private room that they try to like model
after the Lakers uh you know VIP lounge
um the Lakers on the ice house now yeah
Johnny bus uh Jerry's son uh got it got
it going and it's all right yeah it's
fun yeah you do Miss anytime something
gets like completely you know redone I
think you miss a little bit of get
nostalgic for this is the way it was
yeah completely different yeah I haven't
been there yeah completely different is
your couch still the same now is it
crowd's still the same it's always been
a good crowd it's been wild last night
uh that's a better management now
yeah a lot of people there's more on it
for sure they were bad three years ago
wow and then they shut it down their
pandemic and just dumped a ton of money
into it you've been to the ice house
right I have no clue what you guys
talking about uh we we like to hang out
where they make ice like uh because it's
uh it's a place you ever go to the gas
station you get those bags of ice you
get those bags yeah right so if you buy
the bad guys just to distract from the
back you're buying condoms so these guys
hang out where those bags come from yeah
and it's great and the Lakers bought the
place where they make the ice right and
it's not the same anymore we should just
be able to sit there and watch them pour
the water
and make that ice and now now you just
have to the Lakers are doing it yeah the
Lakers doing not the same that's I hope
everybody's go fast today me too but I
gotta tell you I gotta tell you I have a
special reason so you posted the fact
that we were going to be watching this
with you yes sir and uh on my my uh my
Twitter feed lit up a little bit more to
say don't go to the bathroom there
because you piss in the sink
where what did they said that you you
said this out loud wait don't be piss in
the scene I've done it maybe I've seen
it once okay but I mean nobody's talking
about the fight everybody was saying
Howie how are you gonna go there he
pisses in the sink he Brennan's talked
about he pissed in the same I had to pee
in the sink one time is a state of
emergency I'll be honest we're with the
toilet I mean you gotta have a key it's
like Alcatraz it's it's a dicey security
I'll be honest if I met you on the
street and somebody pointed you and was
like that guy's a sink pisser and they
ran away I probably would go yeah that
checks yeah that's right yeah the face
usually matches the crime but also you
seem like you carry yourself with a
Swagger of like you know if I gotta go
I'm gonna go right now oh it was I mean
I'm telling you it was Terror level five
how did you either pissing my pants on
air or doing it right there behind the
sheets well next time commit to the bit
and just see what happens yeah it's not
a bad idea
one word catheter oh you don't have to
ever leave or depends right it depends
yeah yes pamper yourself what is the age
you think depends you can start doing it
and people don't judge you 22. I try to
uh they they were gonna do a campaign
with you well no I pitched me great I
wanted to pitch me they didn't buy it I
threw my agent I said let me be the
depends guy you know and because you you
would take that product through the roof
yeah because number one I don't want to
use the public bathroom like here yeah
I'm just comfortable and I thought I'd
be a great spokesman where I can just go
listen the pens just I never miss
anything I am there for it all
wow just a little right close up as you
zoom in yeah it's a montage of you being
super busy you don't have time to take
back that's right you can't stop it
don't stop that starts trending and then
we'll all just pee in our pants and then
you add a little uh humor to a product
I've pitched myself for a bunch of
products well what happened huh what
happened there yeah a little cough yes
oh how if you do not cop if you get
something in your throat just deal with
it because Howie will walk off did you
ever smoke pot yeah yeah so it's just a
little residual uh you know weed weed to
the throat from the ice no no Mr Ryan
Garcia you gotta you gotta you got a lot
going on my man big fight announcement
yeah tank Davis now April 22nd are you
nervous no really no too undefeateds too
undefeated not even an ounce of
nervousness wow it is a big it's the
biggest fight in my life I just don't
feel nervous oh it's one of the biggest
fights of I mean probably in a hot
second next like three years I mean last
five years this this fight has been like
rumbling in rumors and was supposed to
happen and finally you know once the
Fighter's announce it you know it's real
it's like it's an insane fight so
Javonte Davis I think was he 27-0 he's
28.0 I think 25 Knockouts but he's like
show times like he's he's the main guy
pay-per-view guy and he's a knockout
artist and then you know Ryan is this
young knockout artist undefeated
obviously
you know we're both knockout Fighters uh
I wield this into existence you know I
was uh I was so determined to make this
fight happen so like I'm just so happy
it's finally here that's why I'm not
nervous about it because I kind of
manifest I wanted it more than anything
in my life so every every like step to
it now it's like it's here I'm ready to
like you know you can't go into the ring
nervous no I mean that doesn't whereas
you may be in a slight nervous right but
in comedy somewhere allowed for a little
bit yeah sometimes nerves help you yes I
think in fighting
I does it I don't think it could help
for me it's like I used to be like have
problems where you know I would get
nervous really nervous before fights but
it would never be about the fight it
would just be the thought of me losing
the pressure yeah you know just kind of
random thoughts that go through your
brain but once I kind of learned how to
conquer that now I don't get nervous and
I perform way better more efficient when
I'm in the ring I don't get tired as
much so once I conquer that I feel like
it does help how much do you weigh dude
dude dude you never ask a [__] oh yeah
yeah
Jesus
sorry about my friends
what's your body weight what's your PIN
number you know what I'm saying like
what are we doing here yeah you don't
say that I didn't know that that's the
first time no no you don't have to say
the amount of weight I have to lose I
mean you can't ask that question
you look at me with so much sincerity I
was like [__] yeah yeah
but you uh why Javonte Davis out of all
I mean there's a lot of big names like
because I think that um if you look at
it like most people even outside of
boxing that's the fight they want to see
other than you know Earl Spence yeah
other than maybe Earl Spence and Terence
Crawford like this is the fight to make
and uh to really bring I feel boxing bat
in a way where it's we're gonna fight
each other and we're gonna get it on
where are you doing it it's gonna be
Vegas whoa T-Mobile is that the spot is
that like if you're gonna have any like
you said it's the biggest fight of your
life and if they were to allow you to
pick like where that's gonna be it's
Vegas usually for any fighter like yeah
I want to do it there that's the Vegas
or New York right I feel like it's going
to be either Vegas and now Dubai right
obviously what's wrong with like Rancho
Cucamonga you know what I'm saying I
feel like there's I mean that's cool
you know what I'm saying yeah do you do
the training like the the the uh
high altitude training do you do that
have you done that I've tried that I
just I didn't find any benefit the first
time I did it so I kind of well I know
when I go to Lake Tahoe I have trouble
with stairs you get it you travel so I
wanna I wanna ask you though I think and
I'll ask you one more question and then
I'll leave you alone right you said you
don't get nervous I feel like nerves
come out of lack of preparation and
Trust right right and so like when I was
talking about comedy we go up there we
want to allow for a little bit and the
uncertainty like of what's gonna happen
with the crowd is always adds to the
fact of maybe like oh this could be
you're still trusting yourself that
you're going to be able to make the show
great after a certain number of years
but is the adrenaline so sometimes
overpowering that that's why the nerves
are just non-existent because you
getting ready to walking I just feel
like once you are at a level you're at
and you're walking in you're just so
confident but the adrenaline I can't uh
imagine is comparable to anything we've
done the adrenaline right before the
Bell Rings is probably yes could get to
a level where it's like you know you
you're gonna feel something but it's
it's not gonna make me like you know not
for like forget what I'm gonna do or
anything like that but yeah but the
moment before the battle is probably the
most nervous feeling you can feel it's
like crazy all right it's [__] here
now
once the Bell goes and you're in there
it's like being on stage you know like
if it's a big video or a theater or
something like dang there we go yeah
then once you grab the mic and you get
the first laugh like oh here I've done
this right right same with fighting like
the build up in Walking the ring and or
the octagon it's just like geez but let
me ask you something so you walk in to a
fight and when you when you listen to
people training and I'm not in the fight
game at all but you have a plan right
you have a plan you've been watching
tapes and like us we go up on stage and
you have a plan you know what that act
is but if the audience kind of turns on
you or whatever you got a Veer is that a
tough thing for a fighter to kind of go
against your plan it's like a plan plus
improv so you have a plan but then you
have to do improv at all times like
you're always adjusting from you know
the opening bell okay he has his hand
down here boom hit him here boom as
Tyson said everyone has a plan until
they get hit exactly like you might have
a plan to stay outside and be pretty
like I'm sure Tommy Fury has tonight and
then when you get hit it's like okay I
gotta switch this up this isn't working
do you tell people if you you know like
in our uh world you do something off the
cuff you know hopefully it goes so well
people are like dad had to be been
planned right just because the way you
kind of you know navigated through the
the organic moment if that happens to
you in the ring do you do you clock that
you kind of pass everything off as like
plan and prepared or are you like yeah
no that was a off the cuff moment as far
as like something happened and I reacted
and whatever the truth is yeah and I was
like oh I planned that shot for the camp
and I landed it I'll say that if it was
like a reaction I'm gonna say that
whatever it is what's more fulfilling
or whatever does the job gotcha good
answer so this fight does it give you a
title is it a title fight uh it gives me
bigger than titles yeah this is I mean
he beats Javonte Davis like knocks him
out and they're both knockout artists
like wow it's insane it's gonna be
whoever wins this fight should be the
next face of boxing whoa I would say
that so how important are titles then
you don't care about time I mean I've
been on record to say that right now
titles don't mean anything
they're making anything up it's I don't
even know what it's called it's like the
it's like a that's the truth no it and
it does rhyme with like the diarrhea
it's like diarrhea belt or something
like that diarrhea belt the diarrhea it
sounds like that in English but it's in
Arabic it's very strange
but either way they get it so you don't
care about uh
no I cared more about like a gold medal
as a younger fighter but now now it's
just like but when when you look at
Javonte Davis I mean obviously the guy's
doing something right right I should be
a world champion beating him right I
mean 100 so with uh Javonte obviously
you know has nasty left hook and has
power stuff like that so you haven't
fought a guy of this it's fair to say I
haven't found a guy with this caliber
especially with that knockout power yeah
I haven't fought a guy I wouldn't say
yeah I would say never found a guy with
the power or explosiveness so it's um
it's obviously going to be a high level
fight I'm fast I'm explosive so you know
you're gonna have two guys that have
great timing and uh oh I can't wait that
I mean you get it you get when is this
finally Prime versus Prime at the right
age yeah right timing how old are you am
I allowed to say that yes I think so
yeah no one's a little
diceye
how old are you 24. okay yeah and and
how long because this fight was tough to
put together yeah it took a six six
months because there's like rumors
there's go back and forth and then I
wasn't going to take a fight other than
this fight and what was the hold up it
was like the rematch was the rematch
clause an issue I saw yeah that was a
little issue um from the beginning he
always wanted to extend it you know he
first we said December I wanted to take
a tune up into October that of last year
right and he was like no if you do that
we're not fighting so we're not fighting
in December I said okay whatever and
then
who comes December he doesn't want to
fight on his birthday then it goes to
January the fair point hey really then
no not at all yeah okay then he goes all
right I got a table of islands man I
can't fight on that day he said we're
gonna fight in January and then he goes
I need a tune-up now so then he's
fighting somebody else and I'm like name
Hector Garcia so he's like Garcia's and
then um after that you know I was like
you know I'm not gonna take another
tune-up we're going to go straight in
because I'm not going to cost this big
fight happen he say unless anything
happen right I break my hand do
something crazy so I just well you gotta
hope that he gets to the fight obviously
he has some extra quicker activities
outside that's the one thing that that's
the one that's the one that I could mess
this fight up yeah we put we put that in
the in the contract if something happens
with him externally do you like to talk
[__] or is that like distracting
If he if he brings that if he brings the
energy then I'll do it if you're not
initiating no not at all but if I would
imagine he will if he does then it's on
could he say something that could truly
get a like do you have a thing like
you say one thing about my [__] cat
how do you think he's going to give that
to you right now yeah okay
Davis in front of millions of people
you're gonna know my trigger point right
now I'm talking about my damn dog yeah
okay okay fair enough no seriously no I
don't think when it comes to like
talking I don't think anything could get
to me because of where I grew up and how
things are we talking where did you grow
Victorville and it's like a Victorville
yeah exactly dude that's not that's not
Barstow no that's Victor yeah
what uh did you find a lot as a kid in
Victorville we just it was just like
everybody's talking [__] all the time
and did I fight I never been a street
fighter in my life I was scared I'm
scared I'm actually scared to street
fight now not now but now you've got to
be more scared because you could get
[__] up and then you can't do this or
you could figure out yeah yeah but as a
kid I was terrified to fight it's like
what were the types of uh kids that were
I guess thrown down that made it uh a
scary possibility nothing it's just the
fact that we're fighting like it just
felt like right I would get scared is
there a tough area Victorville yeah well
where I do Adelanto it's pretty it's
pretty tough yeah
it's all good how'd you get into the
fight game were you in were you uh I was
a baseball player at six years old right
and then uh I was I didn't like the team
sports so I asked my uncle I said uh is
there any sports one-on-one and he
showed me a clip of boxing I just saw
him and do it that was it who did he
show you I don't even know you remember
he just showing me two guys fighting I
said I'll do it and where do you go to
do it I just trained in garage my whole
house let's get a bag right that's why
that's what that's what made but who
gave you the who gave you the punching
bag this is my uncle so he bought me
gloves does he know how to box he had a
he was like the old timer was like you
know he's like one two one two one two
three like there's like yeah oh yeah
right hook left hook nothing like you
would say like okay like you know that
not like uh he was never a professional
or nothing like that but I fell in love
with it quick but if you see his hands I
bet your uncle said yeah you're insane
oh my God no that that's what I know
that's what I did notice when I was your
uncle still with you yeah is he will he
be there in the corner oh yeah no he
won't be in the corner but he'll be he
must be losing his mind does he take
he's
I've got a step uncle who told me if you
ever find yourself in Phoenix I know a
massage parlor that takes Bitcoin and I
was like dude this is why we don't talk
a lot right you're weird that's why he
that's he asked his uncle he didn't like
team sports he said is there a
one-on-one thing your uncle showed you a
fight
yeah different could have went either
way awesome uncle one on one awesome any
fights in Canada growing up because you
were you said you were small so I'm a
runner yes people wanted to beat the
[__] out of me but I run I'm a runner
I'm defensive my technique is defensive
someone say that's smart
are there Jewish boxers do we know of
any yeah
well not now but
yeah
Max uh what was it Max schmel yeah yeah
maybe yeah now right looking at a couple
Jews here what would you say if we were
to jump into the ring let's say tomorrow
right what would be the first thing you
might throw at us as far as like getting
us something move your head protection
you're gonna die
in the Heyday this is a new Heyday
you're creating a new Heyday yeah but
but because boxing for me is kind of
like over it's just coming back boxing
was big when I was a kid who's fighting
at that time when I was a kid yeah it
was mostly uh cavemen yeah I'm old Jesus
[Laughter]
yeah anybody on Mike Tyson Academy Mike
before that yeah and Kayla remember
Lennox Lewis claimed Canada yeah but
everyone's like I don't think so dude
trying to remember who is that blonde
guy he fought I I went Tommy Morrison
that's who it is he's Canadian wait wait
no wait Mike Tyson uh no Lennox Lewis
I'm trying to think I went to see it's
Caesar's I'm trying to remember who it
was I was at the fight this is not a lot
a lot but I was at the Holyfield Tyson
fight holy [__] and I was sitting that's
what I said and I was there and really
close to the to the uh is that is that
the one with the guy the bite of the ear
bite but it was was that the same one
where the guy came remember oh no that
would be stupid no you're talking about
the guy parachuting in no no so but what
I'm saying is you know they kept he kept
clenching clinching him and doing
something and they kept backing him off
and then backing them up and then he bit
his ear but we didn't know he couldn't
tell you couldn't tell no but he bit his
ear and I was close enough to see he bit
his ear and then he goes and he spit it
out on the thing and I remember looking
at the mat going that's not what I think
it is and then I see hollyfield like
he's bleeding in when you see that's
what I was saying get the [__] can
somebody get me a mask there's blood
because that's never been done right
that's it I mean is there any other
moment ever yeah but the argument that
listen I'm not advocating biting
anybody's here did you see the video
where he says sorry yeah but but Mike
says sorry yeah python but building up
to that fight Tyson was frustrated
because uh Holyfield kept head button he
kept headphone and they weren't doing
anything he kept headbun which is a huge
issue in boxing sure it's Cuts
everything so he kept going his head
button he kept head button and then
finally all right forget this if you
keep head butting me you know I had an
uncle one time told me if he didn't buy
anything you know I had an awesome uncle
from Victorville but Victorville
Victorville to all the sweetest uncles
come from uh yeah if you get if you get
headbutted that hard I feel like that's
you're asking for something this fight's
over yeah
he's not it's not only over he's dressed
he's got his metal around his neck metal
he's he's not even really sweating he's
made spring break plans [__] what hit
that out all right now is uh diarrhea
belt it's the dog Brendan that's what it
will be the WBC saying the Fight
Continues to support the growth how was
anyone like that just change that name
because when Americans read that they're
even called the diarrhea like other
belts but you wear the big plaque on the
back yeah on your ass because this is
the diarrhea that's strange that's
ironic now Ryan how do you think Jake
Paul is good for boxing or bad uh in
some ways he's good in some ways it's
kind of bad because he's bringing new
eyeballs right like don't you always
want it you always want an audience uh
you know to jump on board and help grow
the sport right if it does yeah I mean
I'm all for it what's the bad part uh
the bad part that it kind of looks like
a gimmick right I mean
no but some people today
A lot of people are like oh this is like
this is scripted like they just think
it's fake like it's kind of like corny
like WWE type do you think the sport is
saying that as a boxer but can I tell
you as a viewer as a viewer I think he's
playing it really smart I mean he's not
saying he the the the the matches that
he has lined himself up with now he's
not going for I think if he wanted click
bait yeah he could go for people that
are so much bigger where he'd be knocked
out I think he's playing it he's getting
better and better each fight I think
he's really taking it seriously and as a
kid who used to watch boxing boxing was
the biggest thing in the world and these
guys were Superstars and used to show up
at these events and everybody from all
over the world whether they were in
Entertainment Sports business would show
up there aren't any stars at this moment
yeah so for him to be bringing eyeballs
sure and for him to be in my mind taking
it as seriously as he seems to be taking
it the good outweighs the best that's
the right perspective when you say
there's no stars like I think he gets a
huge in a box like he's probably he's
top three in in boxing but he'll bring
more eyes to you even with these things
I think for Ryan what he's saying like
with his pedigree and the way he came up
you know boxing yes in his uncle's
freaking basement you know which is a
great uncle he had a following and then
jumped into the sport is that what
you're talking about the guy who's been
through you know the trials and
tribulations that can come to what he's
become right now so for Jake to have an
audience and jump on over and then get
these eyeballs but anyway I don't
that part I'm not even mad at anything I
just thought like you know what what
could be the good part what could be the
bad part it's because he's white right
good part that he he brings the eyeballs
and and brings more people to the sport
I think that's the great thing the bad
thing is sometimes it could leave a sour
taste and yeah that take it serious yeah
so I was just thinking the pros and cons
but also in this day and age
and also wearing a day an age where and
that's what we're sitting on right now
social media so social media you would
normally when I was a kid just see a
really good fight and you didn't know
and there's so many conspiracy theorists
that say this isn't real right that
that'll start to go away like blue
Mohammed had a great quote he goes when
the hate doesn't work they start to tell
lies so there's been so much hate
towards Jake Paul's doing so much hate
towards Logan Paul it's not really
working they keep getting bigger bigger
then all of a sudden you see uh like
somebody posted oh here's a script for
tonight's fight that's 2.2 million views
yeah or some guy created a fake video I
watched the fight when Jake knocked out
Woodley or when Jake knocked out another
guy we're like oh look it's fake and
they edit it to look like he doesn't hit
him but you can see Claire's day he
rocks him right most a lot of people
like the common fans and to your point
with social media that video of that him
faking they knocked him out I don't know
30 million views the fight only got
maybe a million views so if the
narrative is oh it's fake people that
aren't in the fight business oh it's all
scripted it's fake yeah so because if
when the hate doesn't work the lies have
to work but that's not just sports
that's the world that's the world yeah
so nobody is living in we're all living
in our own reality whatever we decide
whatever our algorithm is and comes our
way but that being said overall this is
phenomenal for this sport don't you
think I know he's taking it seriously
don't you think that that's why I'm
sorry that's why I appreciate him
because I've seen him train like kids he
could do anything Jake and Logan could
play checkers and get millions of
dollars but they decide to do the
toughest route in all of professional
sports being a boxer is a nightmare so
for them to do that and then also what
what Jake is doing is right now I'm too
young yes he's stepping up and he's
taking it smart and slowing P the
audience goes we don't see him fight
Ryan Garcia we'll find uh see him
fighter Canelo it's like whoa easy he's
stepping up stepping it up and then also
I have two young boys if I show him
boxing right now they're young they're
like I don't want to do this I show them
UFC they're like oh my God this is
amazing but when you have guys like Ryan
you have guys like Jake Paul then the
younger fan base goes oh this is
actually cool Ryan dressed as well Ryan
speaks well Ryan's funny Ryan's dope you
know he's flirting with you yeah yeah
this is that yeah this is a modern I
introduced some face to Justin Bieber
yeah Mike dice taking all the the great
compliments but no the thing is though
people don't understand is Jake Paul is
probably taking better competition than
probably majority of real professional
fighters that's a solid Point talk to
him about that in their first what how
many fights did you have now he has was
he six he's yeah I mean the level of
competition he's had he's been doing it
three years right in comparison to most
even myself
is way better than than yeah like I said
just so the audience knows when you
first started boxing like look at Tommy
Fury Tommy Fury so he's eight no yeah
his record of his the guys that he
compete against coming up and this is
normal the record's like 15 and 200. he
fought one guy not joking he was 12 and
200.
maybe it's not for you my man yeah 12
and 200. he he went to like a decision
with that guy but that's how it goes
like when you're first you want like you
you don't want tough fights yeah so when
people are dogging on Jake Paul it's
like for him to fight Woodly like he's
not a real boxer I know but compared to
the guys that may weather fought yeah
Muhammad Ali fought in their second
fight is insane I was reading this level
he's stepping up faster than any of
these guys not even close is it this guy
Calvin Anderson is that his name who was
uh he was training with Jake Paul I was
just reading some article uh yesterday
before this about I think that's his
name uh um and uh crazy size crazy ties
okay this crazy tie break brought to you
by Doritos both of them he was basically
saying that Jake was doing all these uh
moves that he didn't think he could do
and he was like there was nothing on the
the plate or the menu that he um that he
was like I don't think this guy is uh
you know has any weaknesses that uh
there are things that he thought he
couldn't do that he was doing and he was
like overly impressed he's an athletic
kid and then him and his brother grew up
wrestling in Ohio at a high level so
he's naturally explosive knockout power
also this is what's great about you
can't teach it's what's great about this
country right he's learning now is
defensive yeah what he's changing up is
he was explosive and he just wanted to
knock people out and I think what he's
what I've been reading about is he's
focusing on defense because he knows you
know you're gonna be you've got to sting
like a bee but you gotta float like a
butterfly yeah also let's be honest this
country is great about life that's
Deontay Wilder he used to be the
heavyweight champ that's Devin Haney I'd
love to see you fight David Haney yeah
we fought six times amateurs in amateurs
yes and how did that go three and three
so that guy right there is fundamentals
Ryan's fundamentals are ridiculous but
Ryan it's crazy not that power that
guy's jab is the best I've ever seen his
fundamentals he's always had that his
job is filthy man
yeah I'd love to see fighting I've had
I've had the left hook he's always had
the job yes so he's a mover and I I I'm
I'm great at timing people so I would
time him some fights would go my way
some would go yeah like Ryan to knock
you out Devin Haney is going to beat you
down by decision he does not care Jake
Paul's nickname is a problem child
what's your nickname
yeah well that's right he's little King
right I don't know yeah well it does wow
Adam first man but that's cool King's
cool though yeah
that's cool kids
let's be honest though you have to I
feel like in your sport or maybe not
have to is the right word but like I
don't know you do you you didn't give
yourself the nickname did you get to a
point where people kind of crowned you
like that give yourself a nickname yeah
you can yeah you can people do not in
your sport but people do I did King of
Pop I couldn't think of anything so I
just say I just whatever made sense did
you have to get to a certain level in
your mind where you're like that's gonna
be an appropriate label like were you
all alone like your first fight
no it's your first fight in Victorville
man be cool you're like yeah just refer
to me as king yeah yeah I guess but um
yeah just there's another king Gordon
Ryan right did somebody give you the
name or do you give yourself something
the king yeah I said you couldn't do
that wow and it was because you were
like I'm the king of the sport or you're
like
or whatever sounded good too yeah King
Ryan I kind of first used to be called
The Fly I used to be called The Flash
that's what was given to me I like that
because of your [__] fast hands yeah
yeah his hands oh yeah what is there
have you said like records for like I
probably could yeah I'm not gonna yeah I
probably could
yeah that one was probably the fastest
level right there the second video the
second video yeah this one yeah that one
you can't really play it though so oh
you can't play it really you know it's
on Instagram I'll put it on right let me
ask you a quick question that top video
on the right I watched like nine times
yesterday when you hit this I think
holy [__] when you hit the guy they even
said the commentary was like he hit him
right in the liver I was like dude could
you feel that you were like you know
like ending an organs like what does
that feel like when you like right there
like that to me was so yeah dude I know
what was special about that I had like I
had want to know what was special you
know what's great about that yeah he's
gonna piss blood like 50 years yeah when
he was in the hospital for three no but
like
I had so many like weird like weird that
weird but like I had premonitions and
visions that I did that like you said
manifestation from two years ago though
I literally seen the exact shot so when
that happened I was like I was like
literally going crazy I was like I can't
believe that really happened like I seen
it like
it just came in my mind one day like and
I never knocked nobody out to the body
in my life it was all been headshots so
the fact that like that happened and I
got dropped too I was even thinking that
but when I was when he was down and they
were at eight I was like yo it really
happened like whatever was like created
in my mind like that it was crazy did
you see an opening or did you go all
right I'm recognizing a pattern so if he
does this again I'm gonna just go what
happened is I heard him to the Head
like in the fifth round I think I caught
him with a hook over the top and he kind
of stumbled so I knew that he was so
fearful of it and then I just drove
everything I could to his liver with
that left hook yeah what kind of
relationship do you have with uh Oscar
De La Hoya obviously he's the Golden Boy
represented in Mexico to the finest now
like now it's a shame too like the
younger generation
oh they have no idea how good Oscar De
La Hoya was it drives me nuts yeah you
know like now he's obviously done some
stuff yeah he's out there and whatever
but yeah as a boxer man he was he I he
was somebody I looked up to as a fighter
right yeah Jim Floyd Manny Pacquiao
Muhammad Ali
those guys right there you know this
ones I watched a lot Roy Jones Jr is it
almost like with uh stand up where you
know clients here he won't answer your
question
because because uh Oscar's you know who
owns gold he owns golden bullet yeah
I'm not trying to cause any no no
it's just no I don't talk to him every
day it's cool yeah calm up right now
chin get him one more I'll call him
right now but it's in a little bit of a
show because to me it's a little bit of
a shame like the kids don't realize like
what he represented yeah
awesome uncle right now
you don't know you have YouTube you
don't use it
titties and clits and you have all these
great Fighters at your disposal
give me a Fresca
yeah about how much I love Fresca as a
kid that's a pretty short callback
people love those yeah
there you go dude let's take a
commercial that's right
what are you doing it's so refreshing
what's your go-to soda if you have a me
day a tree drinks I haven't drank soda
in so long they were three years maybe
four years but really but when you did
healthy no I just I lost my like I just
unless you're taste soda just make blows
me up so quick gotcha yeah
what is your diet during a day like
what'd you have for breakfast today
great question I don't eat till two you
don't eat till two no matter what even
if I'm not like getting ready for a
fight I just like fasting I feel better
when I don't have anything in my body
too yeah and then what and then what do
you eat it too um
I don't know whatever like my
nutritionist Chef like has made for me I
don't really think about it or you have
a chef yeah wow that's the best how
would you have a chef no only he could
have 15 shoes but
my wife has never cooked anything okay
never 43 years married and she's never
made anything she didn't get her on the
phone call Oscar De La Hoya
just caught Oscar ever made it I'm gonna
make a diet book where it would take all
her recipes I'm telling you if you eat
what my wife makes you will lose [__]
guaranteed wait it's horrible man wait
did you ask questions quick thank God
yeah hey you called it you said you
wanted a quick fight too I just wanted
to get out of here because I got a piss
and the sink is not you hold it he won't
go oh man I feel like a Hell's Angel I
pissed in that sink yeah I feel like a
real Rebel do you think this guy by the
way with the the uh the ref like do you
think if push came to shove he could
like knock both these guys out he's got
a vibe in the guy who's the ref the ref
yeah no sir really why why we don't get
paid to be in there I'm trying to figure
this out but like I would die but why is
he you do you see the way he was holding
up the the numbers in in
um uh Jeff Ross uh face he was like five
six seven yeah I can count [__]
he's passionate dude well what is this
guy have refs how many refs have been
knocked out I would imagine that's right
yeah and the amateurs I've seen of ref
get slept this guy that's because in
amateurs they're always like too close
yeah it's not a wrestling match back
that floor because they're always trying
to do something yeah trying to do too
much their egos I would ask this ref
where were you on January 6th and what's
your favorite ice cream flavor
cup is Fresca still are they still
producing fresh that good that really I
mean do they make it's okay wait uh Ryan
we didn't get together for a new sponsor
is that what you're doing hell yeah
which may be your treat like if you're
gonna have a day like let's say you you
win your fight coming up here and then
and then what is your birthday it's your
birthday
or what like just like like what's your
go-to cheat meal oh cheat meal yeah um I
don't have a go-to cheap you know just
turn up go crazy you know what I mean
Pizza drink oh so yeah yeah we drink
gotcha whatever yeah what do you drink
tequila yeah yeah sure yeah yeah are you
just agreeing or do you know the answer
yeah I'll try it I'll try it out hey I
try yeah I try I guess I thought you
guys
what's the date of your fight April 22nd
okay yeah
Big Boy fight so they're still being
made
that's gonna be uh Al Haymon and uh and
Oscar right yeah yeah because I don't
even know who tanks he didn't have a
promoter anymore didn't Al haymonster uh
what'd you say Al Haymon was he
circumcised me yeah oh cool so when a
Jewish boy is born
um the rabbi or Al Haymon will come in
and uh
well Ryan you said you wanted to
describe this so yeah he hit me up on
Twitter and was like dude if you talk
about circumcisions can I be the one to
break it down so yeah it's basically
what is it yeah wait so you Oreo
McFlurry gushers you won't [__] with any
of that
although you're crushing it don't listen
to us yeah I just that's crazy I guess
just old school huh yeah dude
now when you got a fight April 26th how
do you do something every day pretty
much every day what do you do like give
me an idea I wake up and I go run at
least five miles
and then from there I'll do strength and
conditioning from 12 to 2 and then I
train at eight from eight to boxing
eight from uh eight to ten what do you
listen to while you run fighter and the
kid or
no I I just know what that is that's
right I just made I just do phone calls
while I'm running
whoa do business you're the guy that
says do you want to extend the warranty
on my car yeah I have no idea that the
insurance warranty one Marriott points
is that you that's me I'm that guy so
you're just taking calls yeah yeah I'll
call my coach or call my dad and then
the training Camp's out of where is it
San Diego still no it's uh right here
it's in it's in L.A now same same so
that's right with Joe now so Joe Goosen
so he he trains out here in uh in L.A
another question so when you're training
you're sparring yes how how can you uh
this is the part I don't understand like
how you get really like us that got your
sparring partner can't shouldn't hurt
you damage the look so how do they won't
hurt you if that by the way is how you
punch out yeah but but the point is that
what do you like so you're really not
getting like when you're sparring you're
not at the level of a fight the thing is
the only difference between a fight
inspiring is that you're wearing 14
clothes because everybody's trying to
hurt people like it's like your sparring
partner is trying to hurt you yeah I'm
trying to hurt them too oh [__] and I've
heard I've heard many smart Partners
I've put them in the hospital I broke
and the flooring Partners know that like
usually when you bring a smart sparring
partner into mimic Javonte Davis you're
paying that guy to try to knock you out
because if in only way to practice right
in practice if you can weather that
storm then it's going to be easier when
it's see I would think that you would
say listen this is the no the king don't
[__] with the kids
if you can't last more than four rounds
I I'll send you home like so before you
became because a lot of people like
getting out because they get broken down
quick and it's like you gotta go you
gotta go I want somebody trying to knock
me out I want I want it all right
so were you the kind of the guide that
people would hire to come in and try to
like be a spar uh and raise somebody's
game no no I never never did that it was
like but there are guys that do that
right from the jump they try to get
their name or or credibility by being a
guy that goes around taking out guys
that are trying to prepare are these
guys
we got gym Stars you got gym Stars
that's what I'm saying okay yeah you
don't want to be a gym so you could be
the best in the gym but then you just
suck in a fight I don't I've seen it I'm
like it's like a guy at LA Fitness
playing pickup right he'll hit six
threes in a row but then you know he's
got two DUIs right yeah or or you're
like here's a jersey's like oh [__] this
is official and they can't hit a shot
yeah no seriously
it's over
these fights are going quick I like I
wear a dress
I'm actually really interested into in
the main event like yeah who do you got
Ryan
I think if Tommy Fury fights like he
fought last he's gonna get knocked out
me too quick if he fights like his last
two oh my gosh so what are you doing so
Tommy Fury he's similar to his brother
they don't have knockout power and they
sit on the outside and they like to be
pretty and like use their reach and
their distance and sit on the outside
Jake's not gonna allow that Jake comes
in close makes it ugly and has power so
Tommy's not going to knock Jake out
guarantee he doesn't knock him out if he
wins this by decision so Tommy's gonna
dance Jake's gonna come at him Jake's
gonna try and knock his head off so Jake
will eat two or three of his just to
land one and I hope he hasn't gotten
this long he hasn't gotten this many
rounds this is 10 10 Rounds he's never
gone past five right and Jake's done
already the thing about concerns me with
eight this is eight or ten eight eight
but Tommy changed it he hasn't done
eight rounds Eddie no the longest he's
done is five
and Jake's done eight against the ocean
Silva and it was a fight fight I don't
know how you get into the ring and don't
attack like to to have your uh game plan
and approach but it's but like because
of maybe you want to Tire the person out
but also like what I'm doing sometimes
when you back up you get more tired
really yeah yeah a lot of energy when I
come forward I'm more efficient like I I
like at least it was sick
no sneezing no farting
um but like with that's why I mentioning
your fight against tank because you know
he's an aggressor you can do both you
know so it's gonna be interesting I like
I mean obviously I'm Natural Born
counter puncher but yes
um it would be interesting because
sometimes jervante likes to move around
a lot
um try to lure people in you know and
then he'll pick up later so I know what
he's gonna try to do
um and obviously he's gonna try to break
me down and put his uh what is it that
uh constant mental pressure on me until
I kind of give him a shot where he finds
it that's all he's looking for that one
knocked out shot yeah we do that
sometimes but he can't he can't take a
lot with me that's the thing if he
thinks that's that's what's interesting
about the fight I don't know how he's
gonna play it because you guys both hit
so hard and so that feeling out paired
you can't land too many yeah I I'm
actually excited to be in the ring with
a guy like that I want to see what he
could do because he's what five what
five he's short I don't know how he's
gonna play it because he can't box me
and he can't just you know come in so
he'll be good tell you 510 yeah which
for that division yeah he's five five
but he's done he's five fives being
generous yeah really he's shorter than
five they gave me five eleven though all
right
I'll take it would you ever box somebody
over like six eight
uh yeah cool why not hell yeah I won't
go it won't go good for me bro yeah yeah
it's not too many at all what you did
say when I was um you know Throwing
Shade at a fury for kind of dancing
around you said you do have tactics like
that or you have footwork where you'll
kind of slow things down and uh yeah if
the guy has like if he's bigger than me
yeah like just a big dude I'll probably
move around to try to let him walk into
a shot and then move into attack yeah
yeah because that's a skill set like
that's and Tommy will try that but he's
not at the level where he can get away
with it for too long do you judge people
if they they came in with a mask look at
her
Kanye well he's doing uh yeah
the Mexican wrestling
yeah he's a Luchador
he looks like a guy bought cigarettes
from in Grand Theft Auto
it's interesting look but it's not even
on straight where any of his managers
like we're in his matches I came in you
might not want to show your face it's a
big fight do you think his mom's
watching yeah your ski mask wasn't on
straight sweetie so this is interesting
Deontay Wilder I don't know how involved
anybody's in with the UFC but so Francis
and Ghana who's the heavyweight champion
the UFC left UFC to pursue boxing and
bigger fights and Deontay Wilder offered
a contract to Francis zanganu to fight
him in boxing first and then MMA
which is a big deal big deal
Deontay Wilder's a great guy
a little bit great guy great guy the
most passionate person I've ever met my
life
where is he from he seemed very nice
Atlanta I think
just passionate overall he might be from
Georgia no or maybe no he's from Alabama
sorry
if if there's any guy that you would say
that has superpowers is probably this
guy his right hand like he's not good at
fighting at all no his fundamental
garbage probably the worst fighter
you've ever seen But if he hits you with
his right his hands are down and he just
wants to land that right hand but that's
where he gets in trouble when you find a
guy Fury but I mean for him to go in the
heavyweight Division and literally fight
all these great Fighters and knock them
out and then just out of nowhere sleep
them and he has the worst ending you
ever see awful and just feed her off the
ground boom like out it's like weird
it's like if he just touches you you're
one of the greatest knockout artists of
all time his technique is trash by the
way
a hit yeah kind of right he really
hasn't been hit that I mean Fury kind of
[__] him up in their last oh he slept
them right but
oof I love this
I wish I wish Jake was the one in that
mask why would he do that yeah it's like
it's like a big fight maybe you should
just like I would say this definitely
the biggest fight not that's his dad
right there this is gonna be the biggest
fight of his life right that's what I
was gonna say this is the biggest fight
for it is
yeah so it was diarrhea season look at
that the truth look on the title yeah
isn't that weird it's awesome
is depaul's uh dad their manager or
their uh no he's just their dad pops
just pops kind of cool so when I worked
the the for Showtime the Logan Paul
Floyd May other fight I was like the
Logan Paul expert right so I had to go
in and interview Logan and I'd go in
there I was like I bet they're gonna be
a [__] train wreck then be so nervous
fighting Floyd May when I walk in there
and they had it was like a yoga studio
they had like incense burning it was
real calm and Logan's like what's up man
like dude you fight in 30 minutes he's
like isn't it cool I'm like I guess or
shouldn't she like warm up he's like
yeah it's all good man I did a couple
downward dogs no I thought I was gonna
be nervous he goes I've already won dude
I'm not nervous at all I've already won
he goes I'm a YouTuber I'm fighting
Floyd Mayweather cool I've already won
dude he's like whatever happens all good
what an attitude I look over he's like
can you talk to my dad though I look at
that and he's just like sweating so
nervous I was like listen your son's
gonna be fine Floyd's tiny he's not
gonna give him brain trauma if he hurts
him he's gonna be to the body he'll be
he's gonna have liver damage and
internal bleeding he'll be fine he can
overcome that yeah wow dude but yeah
they're just a different level because
you got to realize those kids grew up
with cameras in their face since they're
little so the moment the moment can't
get big enough for it but there was a
point I I think I read where uh the La
Jolla walked in on uh his parents no
walking
I'm just trying to finish your sentence
on Jake before one of the fights and he
goes you gotta you gotta you have to win
it already before you have to win it
it's not in the ring you got to win it
now yeah and I think he's both of them
have taken that to heart and how they
pursue everything Ryan maybe you can
speak to this but just Brennan talking
about uh the Paul's dad being nervous
that's something I think we still like
all fail to forget like your folks
obviously is supportive and um you know
celebrating your achievements but I'm
sure there's a piece of them with every
fight they're like oh [__] right yeah
let's not show it to you they don't they
don't show it to me no my dad and my mom
they've they've been watching me since I
was little so they're not even they know
how much yeah they're kind of the
awesome uncle he worries yeah he worries
maybe this is all his fault he's like
worries about camera time right he just
wants to get in there like oh yeah
there's not the words I made this happen
yeah
are there any great interviews with him
no no no give siblings yeah are they
pursuing it Sean my little brother yeah
he's eight enough or seven or no he's
gonna be on the undercard of my fight
Sean's uh 20 21. he's gonna be undercut
on your fight yeah it's crazy yeah any
same weight class Yes actually yeah wow
so will there ever be a brother to
brother I was just going to say that's
the sibling rivalry I definitely I
definitely wouldn't do it but he if you
ask him he'll say oh he's a Savage the
younger ones always are if you guys do
fight a little uh tip for you my sister
and I shout out to my sister Natalie we
she's a year older we used to get in
fights and my she would throw a ninja
turtle uh at me and a high heel shoe at
my back and then I would give her the
fart cup no the fart cup you fart in a
cup and throw it in her face and uh
strategy yeah wow oh she passed out for
like six minutes I locked her in the
garage and then she'd be she'd make fun
of me for being a fat kid and having
bigger tits than her mom and she was
adopted so I'd be like you mean my mom
right and uh boy this guy sounds like
some underlying down real quick yeah
my mom
just ends the conversation he does
that's a mic drop yeah that's your
finishing move yeah but yeah the sibling
rivalry fights I think people would tune
into yeah that's right uh Jake and uh
Jake and Logan well I had Logan on food
truck this is right when they started
fighting and I was like how's this thing
end and I was like I'll and I I said can
I tell you how it ends you know sure I
go both of you guys are gonna come to do
your thing find all these big names and
then your last fight ever is you versus
your brother he's like you're spot on I
was like really he's like yeah man last
fight ever why not do it now ah yeah
there's too much to do like I think Jake
he beats knocks Tommy Fury out and then
he'll fight uh Nate Diaz then on Conor
McGregor and then right off in the
sunset what happens if Jake loses what
do you think happens right now I think
the world the boxing stops and you're
fighting get canceled I think
Life as we know this is fine I think
it's kind of over for Jake yes I think
that's right yes yeah no definitely
that's where the pressure's at he can't
lose he can't lose this right beauty is
is you know he's doing it he's doing it
he's doing it he's moving up if he falls
down the stairs then then all these
conspiracy theories you know he's just
going he's clickbait he's doing it he
shouldn't be there he can't lose that's
and that's where all the the pressure
comes from so you're saying amazing so
she's saying if you get knocked down you
can't get up again because Chumbawamba
said you can
I get knocked down I get back up here
yeah I don't know I I hear what you're
saying Howie I think he's still I think
he gets one I think you get one no you
don't not at this level I'm without you
guys because he hasn't hit here yet he
hasn't hit the you know I don't know
that within the boxing world he has well
you're done enough well I don't think
they're taking him seriously yet okay oh
my God this is something to watch this
is something to watch it's entertaining
because he's doing it right and he's
doing it right and winning in a great
ways too yeah I think that if he loses
he's proved all the naysayers right and
then who's gonna pay yeah who's gonna
pay to see him continue he'll be able to
fight like a KSI or another YouTuber but
as far as like getting legit Fighters
not happening also if you lose at the
diarrhea Kingdom like I think the story
writes itself right yes that is [__]
show yeah
how many people are watching this right
now
it was the face after that really
enjoyed yeah he's so anytime you hold it
you know the joke said you know it's
going well yeah
yeah there's so much pressure on Jake
but I actually think this is an easier
fight for him than a Woodly yeah I think
Woodley was a tougher fight for him
I think he just needs to get this done
because Anderson picked up a better
fight than I thought he was what'd you
say Anderson
still would mop the floor Tommy now
that's a cool Nick what about the bet
they made that he didn't reciprocate
well his I felt like uh how he's
alluding to his uh in the press
conference is there you go Winner Takes
all and Tommy was like well be cool and
his dad's like wolf do it anytime he's
like hey man
like you just made the biggest money
you've ever made it's like yo for the
winner too yeah he's like no no no no
yeah let's take a step back now I heard
too because this fight this is the third
time was supposed to happen prior to
this Tommy or Tommy Fury's brother right
Tyson Fury he's the to me the best to
ever do it Tommy I'm sorry uh uh Tyson
Fury and then the dad didn't want him to
take this fight because they thought he
would lose it at the time so they're
like oh there's Visa issues and all this
oh so you think that was an excuse
that's what you don't think most people
think that yeah handshare conspiracy
theories there it is yeah and I think
they're just like no now's not the time
let's get another few fights on your
belt and then fight them you know
because right now so you think this is
just a cash grab he doesn't think that I
don't think Fury has a future in boxing
no no no now listen he's my favorite uh
contestant on love Island UK yeah him
and his wife
um Molly May was they were my favorite
so that boy is bodied up same thing for
Jake if Tommy loses that's it
whoever loses is done of their career
yeah they'll still like they might do a
one-off here that story being discussed
belt more than a title more than
diarrhea this is a career Ender right
whoever loses it's like whoever loses
you kicked off the box in the island
forever
right will you watch uh game tape better
for worse what's that uh just review of
your uh match the same way we might
listen to like a 30 for 30 minutes
you know like we would like listen or
watch it I was so confused
we would like review uh set right from
the night before okay to fine tune some
jokes would you sit down and watch you
know in like with a cocktail if like you
know your fight coming up you win you're
gonna sit down with some buddies and
re-watch it like an ESPN classic or
would you watch it or would you want to
remember it as is oh no I wanted to show
you like I write down notes of every
fight that I have let me see all the
things oh wow I want to see the notes
no this guy came with a cool coat huh
she has a great question you guys were
doubting me my boxes what those are your
notes my notes about uh that's a novel
things that I've learned how to fight
about read one paragraph read one
paragraph okay read the paragraph on uh
tank Davis it's just it's just the
entire Shanghai night script I'm down
about like now my training training will
begin at 7 38 so that my body could get
used to boxing and throwing punches
around that time it's like little mental
notes that I remember don't lose your
discipline and yourself in training
because I'll build a habit and other
things outside but these are these
little things I keep in mind
yourself uh don't open with diarrhea the
audience needs to let them come to you
let them come to me
don't give up the information to your
opponent by exposing their flaws and
press conferences just keep your
thoughts here so you'll read these words
a lot of people will be like yo he does
this that and he's giving them yeah
they're like he's always off on his time
on the left hook so in the third round
when he's tired it's like hey dude
they're giving up I just gave away the
[__] game plan
mentioned your podcast Howie Mandel does
stuff because they should subscribe
because Brendan's gonna be on awesome
and how he has great work I've rocked
that shirt on stage a ton of time well
thank you thank you again and you can
get merch yes I'm gonna go listen to him
wherever you get it's a great podcast
I've been on it too we had a great time
well do a podcast
we need to get more fish in that tank I
no I don't want to over I like them to
feel each fish to feel special you want
to have some room you have a crowded
tank I won't say crowded I've I've three
tanks
look at you
some Flex there right no no I got this
entire Studio into the tank yeah what do
you have in the tanks oh do you want to
go down this road dude uh two arowanas
uh two flowers can you make a fish and
have people still think that's a what's
an Arowana arowana is a fish that's in
it's like a piranha but it needs air I
love it no it's just gonna say an iguana
that works at air one no they actually
they actually call them uh monkey fish
because they'll jump out of the water
and grab like like mice or squirrels and
trees
run out of the water to grab squirrel
squirrels squirrels cookies fish and
Waters near trees with squirrels now
like I've never you know oh you've never
seen an Amazon squirrel alley chin look
that up Amazon
well no I got a difference
no bring up uh arowana leaping out of
the water
um it's insane cover over the top why
did you want to get these creatures
because they're called monster fish I
like like you like fish in general yeah
love them yeah
no fish are friends not food wow wow you
should make tea new merch for you yeah
easy Dr Seuss I think that there is
Tyson
well no do it in the Amazon though that
one's kind of like as a kid you wanted a
tank oh oh yeah and I can only my
parents have money is that one of your
first purchases you got so my son was
like Daddy I want fish I'm like cool so
I go there and I was like he was
thinking a little goldfish you came over
the [__] well no I was at PetSmart
and I was like are these fish shout out
to PetSmart so I asked no they suck
don't go there or get your dog there it
is right there flying fish in Brazil
That's arowana right there so there's
the jardinis which are in Australia
there's the the Asian one and then I
have this one that's a that's a silver
one that's what I have right there and
that's it what did it grab the squirrel
that looked like that wasn't a squirrel
you know what look at look how high he
gets I know but there's appreciate the
leap how appreciate the vertical for a
white fish
heavy on the white I mean I would love
to see David Attenborough narrate
Brennan just like going through PetSmart
trying to watch is he cries to buy the
arowana fish it's clearly not a real
fish containing danger or real threats
but he'll bring it home to impress his
children who don't give a [__] anyway
he always wanted a tank with fish that
jump out and eat monkeys which isn't a
real thing but he's a big guy so you
agree
uh that was impressive though that
footage made me more of a Believer yeah
of two of them
this did take a weird turn but I'll tell
you what's not weird after three years
away from the Octagon the greatest of
all time hands down pound for pound
number one fighter of all time in the
UFC John Bones Jones is back next
Saturday UFC 285 and he is making his
heavyweight debut against Cyril gone uh
so he's going for the title here give
him a double Champ here the official
Sportsman partner of the UFC see
DraftKings is here to help you watch the
fight and make some money new customers
can bet just five dollars on a pre-fight
money line and get one hundred and fifty
dollars in bonus bets if your fighter
wins all draftking customers can join
the excitement in the octagon with
DraftKings same game parlays combine
multiple UFC 285 bets into one for a
shot at even bigger payouts so for UFC
285 you have Jon Jones Sarah gone I'm
taking John under five rounds I think
it's a finish there that's where my
money on the props are gonna be great to
get a finish and for John to win so
that's an easy parlay download the app
use code shop show new customers can bet
five dollars on pre-fight money line and
get 150 in bonus bets if your fighter
wins this Saturday at draftking
Sportsbook with code shop show schab
show minimum age eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details DraftKings
Ryan I asked Brennan uh that was great
what his his first purchase was he said
a tank right what was your first thing
left like that was my first purchase
well your first like fun purchase you
said oh no oh it wasn't no God no but
you I hold that thought
um what did I buy it I bought a car yeah
that's what I did yeah the car yeah cool
and a can of Fresca a 12 pack of what
kind of car wow it was the Audi
yeah an Audi something oh you have the
new Hummer you have the electric Hummer
no I worked with with Hummer but I don't
have it oh they didn't let you keep it
just a photo shoot they gave me enough
to buy one but yeah you didn't want one
I hate electric cars it's just not real
it's like you know it's not real they're
not real how did I get here I don't know
didn't you are you real or is it a
hologram you have that whole I have a
hologram you know he has a hologram oh
yeah dude I saw it I do how's that going
by the road places you're probably in
Dubai right now sitting Marine side are
you guys betting did you bet this fight
can you imagine I've talked about all
this [__] about time like I'm taking
Tommy miles for it yeah
a thousand dollars
and what is that what are the odds what
is it's uh
favorite Yeah Yeah by a lot yeah big
time
yeah
wow so how much can you win uh not a ton
so he's a plus 170 right so I have to
put um
minus 170 for Paul but yeah so 1700 to
win a thousand so you're at 2700 back
under four the the I I put money on Jon
Jones the day his fight got announced
against zero guys I wonder what she's an
underdog what is this last guy had a
skirt on this guy's got a row I mean
it's [__] Dubai makes you feel weird man
have you been there Ryan no no me
neither I have no desire to go either no
really it's too far oh no I haven't had
a desire to go either but I'll go for a
fight I would go for stand-up it was
like workout go but I wouldn't go on
like Victory oh no yeah for sure it
covered his face yeah I'm the kick but
everybody what everybody your device
said Is Awesome
who absolutely loves says it's uh Vegas
on steroids unless you're a woman that
gets dicey but still everybody does
everything on steroids yeah there isn't
anything you can't do there no there is
no toy to not play with what in Dubai
yes yeah and their car collection toys
and what like hovercraft or like
anything you want to have both wow
for real
I think so it's supposed to be insane
out there
but how far of a flight is that chin
from LAX to Dubai this is too far 15 or
16. but people say guitar Airlines which
I've never flown I love supposed to be
unreal if you're in first class well you
don't want a flight of Dubai in economy
no you know if you're going to Dubai
true you got to go first right I guess
you'll be a private Jet's not big of a
deal 15 hours
my pilot coming back uh from Seattle
last night hiccup burped into the
microphone
Abu Dhabi is 18 hours 18 hours yeah
how much 18 hours 18 hours and 40
minutes chin how long when we uh toured
in Australia how long was that 59. yeah
it was like 15 14. no that's longer
right it's only 14. Sydney's like 14.
Sydney was like 14 or 15. but you got to
fly to Atlanta that's four so that's 18
hours
but did you get a good crowd there yeah
great they're amazing what were the
venues what kind of venue theaters wow
yeah how you've been Australia to
perform no oh bro no I don't know I
don't go anywhere 15 hours yeah 14 15.
last night yeah yeah
wow and that that was the audience I
wanted you to be there the most they're
like all Perth was like yeah why aren't
you going to do a chewy
with Adam DeVine we did an Australian
tour and we were in uh Brisbane and you
know Chewie is uh you pour beer in a
shoe drinking I'm not sure the exact
origin story but we did at the end of
the show I was sick for three days
athlete's tongue yeah the crowd went
[__] how he would never do a shooting
because a real shoe just sucking up the
spit into the shoe then pour the bear
and then oh yeah
Australian chewy I did that and I I
threw up what the [__] yeah just put the
beer in the shoe no no I want a party
dude
you want to be Australian or not man
would be the spokesman for Fosters this
is it or not I did a show with those
guys I got very sick all right never
mind
yeah no one and then I I'm going back to
uh UK in June but last time I was right
now Dublin yeah I didn't know this
someone handed me a drink and it's a
Guinness but with uh like uh what was it
chin it was like some sort of current
it's called current black currant black
currant it's like a black cherry like
yeah fruity thing apparently you don't
do that it's delicious don't do that out
there but they could tell because my
beer was purple and they were booing I'm
like what the hell are they doing like
you're a drink I'm like oh really and
like we don't do that out here I'm like
oh but who gave it to you the bartenders
bartender there was articles
I think you knew maybe you could bring
your own bartender like he brings a chef
oh that's what that's the move
yeah we saw articles written about it
they actually made articles about him
drinking freaking black oh it was like
uh North American gay comes to Dublin so
you switched it up and then they I know
I didn't switch it off no I doubled down
once I knew that pissed him off I
doubled down that's awesome and I got
shot you pumped to go to Glasgow
Glasgow yeah are you going to Glasgow
I'm going to Dublin I I forget it's like
Dublin Belfast London Manchester
Ireland's incredible
oh buy tickets there you go yeah it's
available right now just want to
pre-sale you've been to London before
yeah yeah I toured out there chin you
came with it yeah it was amazing dude I
will never forget those memories they're
amazing
next week we have I think we start our
JFL London is is all right now at the O2
this fight's gonna end quick
yeah I'm in the O2 in London it's uh oh
I forget the exactly this gloves look
bigger
it's sold out that's sold out
I don't know where I'm going here's your
dates what I'm doing I don't think I've
ever seen title how are you currently
filming AGT right now I'm doing cgt
which Canada's Got Talent amazing and we
just finished AGT All-Stars and then at
the end of March I start AGT again so
I'm like at a I'm in like a whirlwind I
don't know last night I was in Miami
I don't know where and what were you
doing out there I don't know it's just
uh you sure I don't know I don't know I
don't know what I'm doing here fear I
just don't know thanks for saying it out
loud man because we all look at each
other being like who is this guy yeah I
don't know how did he get here I don't
know what the [__] wait how uh Canada
what do they bring to the table that
America is not uh stepping up to the
plate with are you really yeah Justin
Trudeau
Justin Bieber Cirque du Soleil sure
Justin Bieber sure every movie you've
ever loved Gretzky God damn it okay
here's what America's got Tony Robbins
Will Smith Pillsbury doble Fresca Fresco
yeah I see your Bieber and raise you
Fresca we have a lot of times
Jim Carrey who stood out though like in
this like what act what type of act
stood out there is an act that is my
golden buzzer this year this one's gonna
start uh March 21st there's an act I
can't even tell you what it is this uh
it's a girl that makes noises
[Laughter]
you have to make you have to do the ADR
yeah
ADR if you [__] it and then you put in
you record sounds later not when it's
happening yeah man I don't have my own
Chef I gotta do multiple jobs over here
at the ray house not even two o'clock
yet you haven't eaten no no I want to
eat though it's not two yet you can't a
Jewish mother yeah you gotta eat man
what are you gonna eat at two o'clock
what are you gonna throw down I don't
know whatever the chef has man yeah you
don't even say you know what I'd like
I'd like some keys no because I have to
lose so much weight so I just stick to
whatever how much you weigh right now
you got another knock knock
152. you got dropped yeah the other guy
was like horrible
yeah
I was gonna say yeah
there's nothing I'm good that guy came
with it
he got a rock how do you just run into
it like that you rock got rocked on the
right hand good fight all right
oh
[Laughter]
sure right
Floyd
had a fight in uh Abu Dhabi somewhere in
the Middle East and there's nobody there
do you see this no nobody was there in
the audience you're talking about yeah
there's nothing I don't even know he was
fighting he's just fighting well nobody
knew he's just fighting random people
now
is that like his training partner boom
Oh
that's the one he ran into yeah
I'm surprised I didn't drop the other
guy too it's got a skin condition I was
just gonna say that I hope that's acne
measles that's from steroids
could be psoriasis really I mean I have
psoriasis doesn't look like eczema maybe
no but I'm saying I would I would be
very defensive if I was in the room all
over my back his nickname is back zits
they're like dude didn't even try to
disguise it yeah we're just this is a
good nickname yes Ryan zits Martinez
right z-i-t-z yeah oh
he's aggressive there can't be too many
fights left right you got that co-main
event's a legit fight with Badu Jack
that's 12 bro yeah two more after two
more after this yep
so well no no you have one more after
this than the main event I mean two more
two more okay so you have the the legit
five oh you made a mistake and now
you're just trying to fix it no two more
years
I know but that's not what do you know
see what I'm talking about look at this
ref like looks a little more agile all
right I could say this for us might be
able to do some day but I guess he's
bigger than the two guys yeah
the stadium doesn't look packed right is
that a big Stadium how many are there
that many Jake Paul fans in Saudi Arabia
or
people probably flew out for this too
it's probably a small oh yeah excuse I
don't know I mean people that love the
sport right I take a trip to Dubai never
been go see the fight right the way you
travel to go see the Super Bowl or
something like that yeah
you're comparing the Super Bowl today
all right I was told I would not be
judged for the comments I make on
today's program
uh yeah you're right I mean yeah but I
guess it's a little further away but I
guess this is the salad bowl
I sweated that out but Howie I think
that there's
it says they sold out the arena really I
assume they show up late like in in
Vegas no matter who it is especially in
the UFC they show up just for like the
co-main events right or they were out in
the you can buy snacks and yeah they're
not in the room or they're like buying
Ferraris and stuff then coming back
they don't go in let's go in the guy
with the pimples is fighting
thank you
is this Martinez Martinez this poor guy
dude I know this is one insecurity is
this one insecure oh oh yeah that didn't
feel good
I'm still hanging
his boys are throwing some shots but
it's only four rounds so they're I mean
these are not experienced Fighters at
all right no four ounces
oh I mean he's taking a good it wasn't
trading though
I'm just surprised that guy dropped him
though he's like the little guy yeah
yeah I know all right who would we pick
right now if you're gonna make a call on
this one I'm still gonna go with the
green uh not zit yeah yeah he's gonna
pop him
[Laughter]
yeah
did you hear you hear Ryan Garcia
watched her fight he's like let me oh my
God
that is a great finishing move just take
uh knock him out and then when you and
then roll them over and start popping
his zits and look into the camera and go
I'm coming for your wife next yeah
what and then his uncle goes they're
gonna sell zits merch
you can get a cup of pus
Martinez spots
welcome to oh this is this is what it's
like there welcome to Stan ready on you
have no desires really no it's too far
but I've heard this is probably the most
luxurious place on Earth I know yeah I
heard it's great out there just too far
wow it's like Thailand you've been in
Thailand no I've never been in Thailand
no no no no but no one's traveled a lot
here outside we did this episode of
Young Rock
um where Vince McMahon why playing the
show uh goes to Riyadh to start the uh
the WWF I'm thinking about the jokes but
I think what was great about the show is
that like during the second season we
really got things
so yeah and uh the show you know we just
finished the third season we're looking
to get a Four Season The Rock's Global
yeah because these are like people are
watching Network TV but they're not so
the spawning views is what you get and
then obviously you hope that people want
to go hey you know the story continues
you know I'm listening damn look at that
shot
every [__] shock so much sweat oh
look so much
man
just like he's all [__] you
[__] you big moment it is
but you know teenagers with their acne
and his haircut it's tough to tell
something happened on his shoulder he
popped one I don't know if he's 40 or if
he's 13. it's just cause for a doctor
break freeze and his haircut makes it
worse when he gets pregnant we need a
dermatologist in the real dermatologist
in the corner
Dr pimple popper comes running out yeah
I got this that Asian thing yeah yeah
from Orange County yeah what seems to be
the problem he's taken so many hits to
the face and it doesn't change his
expression it doesn't yeah he's dead he
came to it yeah he is Yo he's verily
open though like that yeah he's skycam I
was gonna say what is he doing wrong his
gloves are so big
now his body is just so small
he does a good job a couple more of
those
I'm surprised this guy in the green
hasn't found like a knockout
I know he's like right there yeah it's
there look he's just waiting he's just
like oh
anything I know to the right there it is
a hook yes lead hook lead right whatever
you want
you need to keep aggressing you need to
keep going first he's tired huh like or
when the guy which one are you talking
about Martinez exhausted
uh you know I'm a zit yeah oh
right is there a moment where um I guess
during any fight where you're like all
right I gotta like dig deep like is it
happen early like energy wise like you
can expend it early or are you pretty
um I guess good at sustaining it
throughout now yeah it's all about being
efficient yeah like in the ring like
don't blow your gasket in any round just
make sure you know but when you get hit
in the head like that and I'm sure you
have yeah you know that kind of rings
your bell a little bit isn't it hard to
be efficient in that you know right now
you're sitting here and you're sharp
it's more than exhaustion just the fact
that whoa I've been rocked yeah I mean
surprisingly not a lot of shots do do
that to unify but there's certain shots
that you've got you get hit and you're
like oh I felt that but you just say to
yourself like yeah I mean obviously you
got to keep fighting did you ever uh get
knocked out even the amateurs yeah any
concussions or nothing I never got a
concussion never my nose is only bled
once I've never had a cut I've only been
dropped once have you ever had acne yes
well not like not like Martinez I'm not
gonna hold that tackle because that
could be like do you fight in Dubai do
you struggle with back acne hi I'm Howie
Mandel with Noxzema
oof
who who else did you come up with in
amateurs uh it was me Devin Shakur oh
yeah who else and you you fell as just
Young Bucks going at it yeah how'd it go
with Shakur uh I felt they they took
that fight away from me I only fought
him once but he was already that guy to
be you know to go to the Olympics like
there he was the man right he was the
man so did you want to go to the
Olympics did you go to the Olympics uh I
made the Olympic team I just didn't end
up going to Olympics because they
changed the age requirements from uh 17
to 19.
so and now that you're a pro forgive me
for my ignorance can will you go to the
Olympics yeah you want your professional
no I think
they did change it but for other sports
I think my likers are going there yeah
so is it not the same for fights you
can't have more Fiverr more than five
five professional fights yeah yeah like
Floyd Mayweather can't go in the why are
you kidding either because they want to
like break people or what it's more of
an amateur thing yeah and I wouldn't I
wouldn't but what then and there's no
benefit for it yeah
basketball is different they also get
and I wasn't saying going to the
Olympics for boxing I was saying for
yeah speed walking there is that is I
know it is I would watch the [__] out of
that by the way Olympic speed walking
have you ever seen a MILF walk down the
street in a hurry so funny
just the speed walking in general is so
funny it is I'm a dilf
okay
damn I love fish oh no whoa that's a
great shirt fish that jump in the trees
for squirrels yeah yeah yeah
Amazonian squirrels I can't believe you
guys never seen them well who's got it
you know who's got it yeah yeah for sure
even though he got a job but he got
dropped in a fight or a fight which is
kind of yeah that's yeah that's good
it's good that's scary going every round
you guys are going to see cocaine bear I
have no desire to oh
you know last night I watched or two
nights it's a true story is a true story
yeah but um two nights ago I watched uh
that movie the the whale with uh because
it's getting all this hype with the eyes
it was overrated it's good it's good
it's good now you know it's a low you
know I think a three million dollar
movie but it's good and what's the
problem he's just like he he he was uh
married and had a daughter and then uh
he was he's always been a gay man but he
wasn't living his truth broke up with
the family and he's a uh you know he
broke with family his uh lover died and
he put on all this weight so he put on
the weight he's like 600 pounds I
thought I'd open with him that big no
you see the progression no it opens that
big but they tell the backstory why is
that big so his depression and then he
uh I love how you segued from cocaine
bear to this beautiful story yes
a lot of but it's good he crushes it
yeah
you can't count to ten without him
getting hit in the head and he's not
going down oh like he gets and he's
getting a lot of good shots two three
four five six seven eight nine this is
the first time
but for sure
is hey Ryan don't you feel like I mean
even with tank like it's weird because
obviously social media is not the end of
all be all but as far as social media
goes you're a bigger star than tank yeah
like your social media presence is
insane 100 I in social media wise yeah
you're the Hummer guy exactly your page
is killing it do you do it all yourself
or do you got somebody posted yeah yeah
cool who's Chef boss yes he's got a
digital Chef yeah it's his uncle yeah
awesome uncle
yeah then Ryan you've been open about
your mental health struggles too like
you've pulled out of fights with mental
health have you always been not let me
put out a one but out of one but you've
talked about it before yes I've talked
about it which is rare for a fighter or
any professional athlete I mean now it's
a little more common but as far as the
boxing like pulling out a fight for
mental health issues I think I was I
don't even know if I was the first one I
bet I was the first one publicly to say
it I think you're the first one the
public yeah what was going down what was
the what was the how was that
reciprocated where was it oh it wasn't
good for me at least but people were
mean to but it was okay you know people
were mean yeah yeah social media I had a
lot of uh well I had panic attacks and
um my anxiety just got to levels where
uh I couldn't I couldn't handle it I
love that you're open but you know
that's my soapbox it's mental health and
I talk about mine and I suffer from uh
anxiety and OCD and depression but I
would think in this sport whoa in this
you didn't go down boom uh Noxzema
that's a chin this sport he is a mental
sport right as much as it's the physical
sport big time how did you how are you
able to uh go up against whatever your
mental health struggles were uh it just
was a time obviously in learning more
about you go to therapy yeah I was going
to therapy and um I took all the steps
that I I just wanted to get better so I
took every step that and who who advised
you to be so open about it because I'm
sure your team was like let's just say
it's a shoulder injury let's not talk
about mental health because again it's
you're the first one to do it yeah was
that your choice yeah it was my choice I
didn't really talk to anybody about it I
just kind of told my team like I'm I'm
gonna just say the truth and that's it
and uh we'll see and you still got
backlash after that yeah
but the thing is I've struggled with it
since I was 17. it was something new it
just got to like a place where and I
don't even know how it truly happened
but I I because I had just won the
biggest fight of my life
was that was Lou Campbell right after I
knocked him out huge fight and I was on
top of the world like I I mean my social
media numbers were even crazier than it
is now and it's very growth from that
yeah yeah it was just it was amazing but
was it the pressure is that what got to
you no I I got to like I just got so
lost like I don't know I can't really
explain it I just kind of like being an
amazing you don't know where to go like
I I just couldn't keep my focus on
anything and then I just kept on
thinking I was sick I I came to like I
became like a true hyper contract to the
point where I was like yo I got I got a
problem for sure like and then I just
kept going through that and then more
panic attacks and I couldn't breathe
half the time so how'd you get out of it
uh talk to the right people talk to the
right people first of all talk to
yourself yeah say this is an issue
exactly being honest with yourself the
truth and then um yeah conversations
with people and understanding that other
people have went through a similar
situation it kind of eases off that that
thing I'm alone in a way like yeah okay
okay okay he understands so now you have
the tools to deal with if it were to
come back again oh yeah 100 but that
doesn't mean it won't come back no what
happens externally has nothing to do
with what's happening internally you
know people I talk about my mental
health people see me on TV doing cool
stuff yeah [__] what are you worried
about but that's a that's an org just
like you can have a kidney go bad like
or get acne yeah is there an influx in
the people once off your first knockout
that was coming at you that created like
also a little bit of the panic like
because I know anyone if they have uh
you know too much going on a lot of
people a lot of cooks in the kitchen
that can add another level of just um
like [__] I just need to quiet
everything down right now
I can't say that it it could probably
played a part right like your uncle's
putting pressure on you yeah for sure
man you know what I'm saying were there
more people like coming at you for for I
don't know for you just I don't know
there's more messages more calls more
people pulling at you I mean Ryan we
want you know and then you're just like
you're looking for a reason an external
reason where I think it's it's from
within no matter what is going on on the
outside and what he was just saying is
from a professional standpoint he was on
he was in heaven you know but that
doesn't have any cure with what's going
on inside and whatever was happening is
you you know it's crazy it's like I was
already feeling that before the fight
but it just it didn't catch up to me
till like right after the fight
interesting because the fight was
distracting right and for me personally
distraction is what keeps me healthy as
long as I'm doing something and when you
finish the fight even if you finish on
top you don't have a distraction then
you're alone with yourself yeah I went
back yes I went back home and it just it
just felt like my thoughts were just
consuming me and could it did you I
don't know if you have a girlfriend did
your family where they're like what's
going on with you man yeah
for sure they were concerned I wasn't I
didn't go to that I just I just
I was tripping out I was tripping out
but how you dealt with it forever the
most successful people I know how do you
deal with it and then still show up for
work do you ever have it when you're on
camera I got AGT I have had it I've had
it and I've been there and I've been
really depressed really where everything
from panic attacks to depression to you
know and and sometimes it manifests
itself where you think you're having a
heart attack and I've been I've been in
the emergency room
so many times and then they tell me it's
just panic but I don't know what I was
panicking at because I'm just sitting
there that's real too hypochondria where
I think you know I got cancer I'm dying
and I can't breathe to just depression
just overwhelming Darkness
I'm medicated yeah you take medication I
do take medication too no I don't no but
I handling doesn't take anything till
two yeah it's true then I'll start
taking my yeah stuff but uh no yeah that
all that stuff that you struggle with
like the anxiety when it builds up then
you become depressed it's like it
combines it comes together and then it's
like oh my gosh now now I feel like I
can't do anything and then I get more
depressed it's just like a psycho but
you know what helped me though is
I look at it with acceptance and truth
it's like okay and then and then I could
just I Feel Free by just knowing that
like you know what let me look at this
situation the most truthful way like
okay I'm having I kind of like detach
myself from sure what's going on right
like say I'm getting a panic attack or
I'm feeling panicky I just it's like I'm
accept this moment I'm gonna just you
know and then I just feel free well most
people just kind of like hide it away or
don't want to recognize mental health
yeah and it's just as important as you
know you're you're fighting every day to
keep your physical health I think it may
be more important Mind Over Matter even
when fighting right it's mind over
matter I mean you have the skill set but
if your mind is not into it or you're
fearful or you let your mind take over
you won't win the fight no matter how
much skill you have and how you've dealt
with this for all your life wow yeah how
do you deal with the post show
um come down and just like the quietness
like you get like yeah
I can't even today you know I can't
that's why when you call me and you say
let's do this let's do this any time I
have nothing to do yeah any moment I
have nothing to do yeah I'm [__] up
and it's a double-edged short right
because for me if I don't have a billion
things to do and I have time to be alone
with my thoughts yeah that but also like
I just uh I need like you said like the
distractions everything it's also fun
but I need stimulus right and when I am
like quiet that's why we'll get maybe
paranoid or in my head or yeah like any
sort of anxiety you have more time to I
guess fill up the uh see that I agree
I'm the same I like to be super busy
when I'm not you know that's where I
have some issues but that's where I
think the kids come into play because
with the kids like you have to be
focused on them 24 7. I don't understand
people in real life in like at 65
retiring like what are you doing unless
you have a million hobbies or something
just to stop that would be hard right
that's you ever see yourself that's why
people die
I I don't but I I'm also in a business
where I'm at the mercy of everybody else
you know if the phone doesn't ring then
I can't just go do
I can't just go work well that's why you
have stand up in your podcast I do
everything my podcast oh yes I have to
mention it it's in your notes yes you're
also having a great example of like you
stay kind and sharp and uh and active
and you can continue to jam and work
yeah it's definitely inspiration for
sure yeah I mean knowing that he goes
through the same things I go through and
you still no I do Howie on our business
idea this we're just butting you up
because we have a huge business okay I'm
in I'm in can I borrow 50.
so now it's an acne cream this would be
the right time to pitch my ideas
we all go through this right yeah yeah
so there's uh yeah there's the co-main
event which Baruch acts like a legit jit
Fighters 12 rounds Janet Jackson shirt
Kevin Devin Haney is he wearing Janet
Jackson yeah I think so a lot of people
are into vintage right now
well Janet Jackson's on tour I wonder if
he is she yeah oh shantor right now yeah
I don't know if I'd see that I could
probably guarantee he doesn't know that
he doesn't know that no for sure
so he thinks he's just wearing a vintage
shirt for not promoting how how old are
you guys the same age Ryan you and I
think he's one year younger
I mean it's just you guys are gonna
fight eventually 100
and dude you beat tank Davis then he
gets a big fight because they they were
talking about him fighting uh
so if he would get a big fight because
you can't go from Javonte and then he
fights some guy we never heard of them
you'd fight Ryan after he beats [__]
Javonte so he's gonna have to get that
key fight in order to get to your left
because you're a step ahead of him right
now yeah for sure
I'll tell you who's a step ahead of
everything is manscaped right they're
now thank you sir they're now selling
beard products not acne products
unfortunately for our boy Martinez
that's right they've gone from waist to
face to help you replace that bulky
razor with their brand new beard hedger
Pro kit manscaped helped you get the
golden rod of Greek god and now they've
created the best tools for you to turn
heads with a clean perfectly groomed and
conditioned beard finally tame your main
by going to manscape.com using the code
shop20 that's schaub20 for 20 off plus
free shipping this kit is about to
change your life the beard hedger Pro
kit has made it easier than ever to
craft your signature look this kit will
take your facial hair anywhere from
Gandalf to totally bear we got you man
the pro kit is much more than a trimmer
though it comes with a dermatologist
tested formulations for your post trim
care all right it has a beard shampoo
and conditioner they got it all the next
kit has manscape beard oil as well well
they have beard balm they get it all for
your Frosty beard so get 20 off and free
shipping with your coach shop 20 at
manscape.com that's 20 off with the free
shipping at manscape.com use code shop20
the manscape beer hedger Pro kit the
premium solution to face grooming
manscape.com promo code shop20 that's 20
off and free shipping with our code
shop20 at manscape.com because just
because you have a fish in your tank
doesn't mean you can't trim your pubes
now you can you what happens if you use
the other uh ins the razor
can use the same one for your face and
your balls yeah I use it for all yeah
you can yeah it's a One-Stop shop that's
a one I put a silly fade on my nut side
yeah
I had you know when I was doing a show
called Deal or No Deal
I had a little uh whatever that's called
oh man too oh no no the soul patch no
soul patch yeah
full yeah not a full I know I was going
through my head I was going that way can
you say full man shoe I'm a full Manchu
a full man that's something you order
from a dwarf in Vegas Yes wow a full-man
shoe as Brad Williams it's a real thing
ask Brad Williams a full name well I
don't want that either way at the waxing
places because dealer no deal was so big
they would offer the Howie Mandel for
women we're getting waxed to get this
little this yeah
they called Atlantis
it was a Howie Mandel you can get a
landing strip you can get you know a
Brazilian or you can have the Howie
Mandel at the time
you're a big deal my son what's better
than a star in the Walk of Fame it is it
is and my son was dating at the time and
can you imagine like he got he like
scored he got away what that
[Laughter]
how isn't that Morgan Martel is that her
name the the the Harry's wife was in
Michigan Megan Megan Marco but you call
her Morgan Mandel oh my God Meghan
Markle I'm really bad you are really bad
I gave her who's that how he meant she
started do you know she started on Deal
or No Deal are you telling me no I'm
telling this yeah one of the briefcase
girls she was a briefcase girls and so
is uh Harry Style no The Duchess Duchess
Meghan markles married to Harry she's
the one that complains about America and
doesn't want fame no way yeah have you
had a lot of briefcase girls go on to uh
super stardom Chrissy Teigen no way
she said uh No Deal or No Deal
objectified okay yeah and you know I
felt I was objectified I have 26 women
just staring at me yeah okay here ladies
I don't know if you know this but the
lead in Two Girls One Cup was a
briefcase girl for uh season two and
three how you can confirm or deny that
the two girls one cup yeah how do you
know which one is the lead with the two
girls great follow-up question we'll be
right back
I know you said it was the lead I did I
know I'm the [__] star here
I'm the star
you follow my lead Brenda I've never
seen I can watch it I don't think you're
not missing out you've never seen two
girls one you should I would drop it no
I can't you've seen the whale with
Brendan Fraser but you haven't seen two
girls one cup one's gonna win an awesome
yeah yeah
a friend of mine bought the rights to
two girls one cup and does it as a
one-man show
his name is Mario Canton
here's the two crazy ties
his thing's more just a bummer bow tie
it's just like oh that's a regular bow
tie it looks like he it's like one of
those ribbons you tie yourself right
it's a sad bow tie it's a droopy boat
should be fun yeah this is sad but
nobody has like a normal tie even all
three of them nothing is normal about
this I want my knot wider than my entire
neck the guy on the the right the middle
guy is just sad he's got a sad droopy
and this guy borrowed his mom's drapes
put her ring on it that's Sean Porter
used to be a great fighter really yeah
but he's not anymore he's done yeah he's
old I think he's done yeah
I knocked out by Terence Crawford
Howie what sport would you uh commentate
if given the opportunity UFC right yeah
me yeah
not me yeah no would I commentate I'm
not a sports commentator but it's like
given the chance for like I don't know
well you know I'm Canadian curling
curling wow for real yeah what the [__]
what is curling yeah you don't know what
that with the isolate that face and
audio what is Curly what is Curly you've
never seen curling do you have a curling
it's an amazing sport taking over you
know what shuffleboard is yes it's on a
shuffleboard on us yeah there it is yeah
it's an Olympic sport hello
and Canada there you go you throw the
puck you slide the puck and then you
have somebody in the sweep Canada
look at that that's that is at the uh
Olympics I've lost a lot of money on
curling the term athlete's very loose
when it comes to this sport
I don't know man the way they have them
I actually want to try it oh yeah but I
don't know what it's the grace sweeper I
mean look that
I think it's very Progressive see they
have the woman pushing the puck and the
man cleaning the floor yes see that yeah
so he's like position it so it can move
a certain way by he's he's trying to
slow it down by speed yeah got it the
more you sweep the faster it goes oh God
you're not wearing skates they're
wearing just like regular old Asics no
one one shoe has a grip and the other
shoe does it I think I just like I know
everything about this sport do you ever
do it do kids do it in Canada these are
spots yeah this is our baseball this is
Canadian baseball mommy can I go curling
and
oh there's Amy Schumer that's cool um
look at that it's Korea against Finland
you saw the the scoreboard Korea Finland
or it's Canada what is that that's
Norway in Canada Norway Norway no but I
saw in the back there was some
pyeongchang is curious but it's great
yeah so and you know
you're trying to knock off the other
person's uh yes closer to the bullseye
yeah is more points are you rethinking
your whole boxing future can you imagine
this is where he quits and takes up
curling yeah I feel like I could be good
yeah I bet they get Hummer sponsorships
yeah yeah well they get the ladies they
get the ladies yeah oh there's Jack the
curler are you serious yeah in the bars
you tell somebody you wear a curling
sweater in Canada
they're gonna they wanna Puck you
there we go there's a lot of paperwork
for these guys look at the amount of
paperwork
especially for a lot of four round
fights too much paperwork fellas it's a
lot and notes and paperwork and printing
and water and a phone but also those
fights have ended I think fast right Jim
so they're trying to make up time right
now they've played this preview seven
times well this Badu Jackson maybe he's
walking out
we got one fight and then the main event
yeah
I know it's 12 rounds yeah
do we have a lot of people watching this
let's keep it keeps I mean not compared
to AGT but you know no be cool Howie 200
no so it was too hard it's different
than what what the actual you know the
account the viewer account will be in
the end but right now there's like seven
thousand no but but then do they watch
this like tomorrow yeah yeah that's
where most of views come from oh really
000 may watch it right now and then
tomorrow is when it starts to go boom
boom boom most people watch it after the
fact oh really
because it's a lot it's a lot you guys
get what for AGT what's the no skip to
the highlights
wow six seven years seven million six on
network TV that's huge it's huge we're
just like the number one yeah I mean
that's equivalent of maybe like what 20.
I stopped watching it but I now I watch
it just just because you're on it thank
you yeah thank you so
um part of the reason I was on the math
singer this week I saw that that's cool
how'd it go I got eliminated what'd you
sing
um ABBA songs how how hot is that how
hot is the suit [__] hot so much
weight
I was wearing a mask under the suit yeah
because you have the mask and then were
you like worried about because that
thing's I have to imagine that things it
was built for me so whatever you don't
worry no I was hermetically sealed in a
lobster outfit dancing and singing I was
amazing and then they cut me because
they don't know how the [__] it well
Medusa's moving on I was the singer and
the dancer and they didn't who do they
guess that you were under the suit Ken
John oh look he's coming out with Tyson
isn't he yeah yeah
why are they framing him out yeah
Tyson looks good doesn't he yeah he
looks really good oh my god look if he
just hit button you just bite [__]
you off okay
are you listening to me
by the way I brought the Mexican gum if
you want them
a joke the comic thing that goes that's
probably cannabis gum he's big into that
oh bro yeah huge big time shrooms yeah
yeah he does a lot right yes
anyone hit you any big shroom guys out
here I heard it help my dude yeah I
tried for the first time with Rogan on
uh the companion I felt great wait on
air you didn't lie we did it right
before we went live I felt good I felt
great I mean I didn't take a lot I would
freak take a little the first never take
it yeah but I wouldn't go away for sure
yeah the micro dose is the move I've
done that full eighth two times and I
talked to a daddy long legs about global
warming and I was like this is probably
I probably should make an adjustment in
the way I'm doing things and my dad you
watch back what you did with Rogan no I
never watched what I do I can't stand
myself but how do you know it went well
you were on shrooms I mean my buddies
had a good time that's all that matters
he thought he was on shrooms he was
actually dry humping a futon at an Ikea
yeah Rogan Brian Raymond there yeah wait
did you so enough to kind of get a
little um for my size they're like
they're saying too much I'm like well
I'm not a big drug guy so I'm gonna take
it easy it was like a small like
mushroom like that big the stem in the
head you don't smoke weed either huh no
I don't like it how come uh I like
feeling out of control
but you'll take a mushroom on a live
broadcast yes but you won't smoke
because it gives you well you want a
line you have a line and that's an
amazing life that's what I'm talking
about
oh man I just hit my stand goal
you're standing standing
I got this Apple watch and it tells me
what things I'm doing I just hit my
stand goal I haven't gotten up in a
[__] hour and I just hit my stand box
oh Ronaldo's there there's your point
Howard you're saying like bringing out
the Stars you got Ronaldo there massive
star but he's he just signed with Saudi
Arabia for 400 million for two years so
that's cool [__] out of here yeah best
time to play I mean him or Messi best of
all time yeah that's like when Beckham
came uh to the US right it's just kind
of it was a pound
crazy like see it's filling in it's
filling in now it's getting bigger yeah
it's getting bigger
it doesn't look like a big arena though
it doesn't
you think there's a prop bet for who the
biggest celeb uh that's going to attend
the fight
yeah it's Ronaldo now yeah it's done
it's gonna be tough nobody bigger than
that no I don't think so all right what
if Scott staff from Creed shows up okay
dude don't get yourself
he might but if two of the three
handsome Brothers Pops in the lead
singer from Godsmack shows up Bop
oh
Deontay Wilder yeah still not beating uh
Ronaldo it's gonna be a tough one to
beat no Mike Tyson Ronaldo as far as
famous yeah that's pretty that's close
because maybe my white rapper
brother-in-law durerte shows up oh by
the way just started UFC Fight Friday
did he really yeah remember I played his
video for you on your podcast pretty
good did you hear a white rapper
brother-in-law darte right uh
my sister's [__] a guy named George I
uh brought up on how he's pot I was like
yeah it's my brother-in-law whatever
he's like oh well let's see him we pull
the video up he's like oh he's actually
pretty good and I go would you send him
through would you give him the gold star
and send him to Hollywood he's like yeah
I was like dude he's gonna masturbate to
this audio
um and he did but he's uh he did a
couple UFC fights shortly after that pod
just for shits and giggles well hold on
hold on easy he was in the UFC no no uh
he did MMA fights
he wasn't in the league no oh no no yeah
MMA fights okay yeah that's like me
playing football outside with my buddies
in the yard like I played in the NFL for
the Denver Broncos you know in all
fairness you have said that but you are
mushrooms yeah I was not sure yeah um
talking to Daddy
no oh MMA I'm sorry MMA they're like in
Seattle I don't know if they do this in
every city or state where there's local
fights okay cool it's like those are the
feeder leagues that could get to the UFC
gotcha so they're winning enough of
those okay then you get to know so
that's mm that's that's MMA prep for the
UFC is what are you trying so mma's the
sport UFC is the NFL of MMA okay so
football's a sport NFL's the league so
yeah that makes sense yes it does so I
was thinking that even a regional
smaller one was a UFC prep yeah like
sponsored by them no that hurts my
feelings gotcha okay so he he did a
couple so he did a couple yeah but he's
uh he makes a living rapping uh as a
white rapper Tyson management I don't
think so no he touched on a man's maybe
he's just buddies with him
it's not a good one I didn't choose who
to walk out with
I I
don't really walk out with people but I
was gonna walk out with you on your neck
that was his pitch oh let's do it
because like we don't walk out with
people no no puppets yeah puppets yeah
because like Floyd walked out with
Justin Bieber Right remember that's like
a spectacle and some people have the
like Meek Mill walked out with some guys
and he's rapping which never works out
no I don't like the like when the people
come out with the rappers no you can't
hear anything no what about the second
leading two girls one cup would you walk
out with her yeah
I'm gonna walk out with you whether you
want me to or not I'm just gonna that
would be incredible
she was Howie Mandel that's the clap we
didn't know we needed
this is the only real fight we've had
this is the really yeah this is 12
rounds like bottle Jack's a beast
he's been doing some Wars yes
where's he from Canada he's Canadian
yeah that's right bring up where he's
from
Jack yes hey I might be right though no
uh it seems
like it hmm we'll be back I kind of like
it against the light switch
he bottled Jack he's no he's Sweden
what kind of story is from Canada yeah
well Sweden Canada it's the same thing
close how you say that
your Jessica is mine man I mean that's a
Fighter's name right yeah
no no I'm just tired he needs to eat are
you haven't eaten exactly and I didn't
get that coffee see oh we didn't get
Ryan's coffee
someone give me a coffee you know we got
some strong coffee
so is this it yeah Oh I thought it was
just here
for your father and Swedish mother do
you want a hot one do you want a new one
yeah if I can that'd be good hey hey
George's can someone make another coffee
that definitely how was that rain you
like that right that rain awake it was
really good really I'm gonna try
razzleberry it tastes really good am I
doing ads for you the gummy bear is nice
where's gummy bear
tropical storm
it's a storm it's still I'm gonna have a
razzleberry which was Howie's nickname
in high school
I can't wait to piss at home and smell
the tropical storms
wait are you we're really home too oh
that's [__] good yeah I'm not going I
wash my hands after I piss and he pissed
it in the sink yeah dude I mean I own
the place you know
he pissed in the sink yeah nobody not
one person that's a true story he said a
true story well I don't know that's your
follower said that oh no I pissed in the
sink yeah it's on record so not one
person said you had that nice ad and
pictures of us and everything went there
and yeah a lot of people retweeting and
doing that excited and and people not
one person mentioned the fight to me
everybody said oh don't use the [__]
thing the sync not one person mentioned
the fight
social media yeah how many followers do
you have on Instagram 9.1 million yeah
wow [__] dude
that's fantastic how many what's your
biggest platform is it Instagram
Instagram and Tick Tock how many you
have on Tick Tock 5.1 yeah I have 10
million oh
five days
out no I dance I gotta check this out
yeah how he also does brilliant videos
your Duets are great I'm gonna follow
you yeah let's follow each other let's
do it I'm gonna be walking out with you
why not exactly we've got to build a
relationship now keep leaning on the
lighthouse this guy looks kind of sad
right
awesome calling out Ronaldo at this at
the fight
boy hope for a knockout here
[Music]
now wouldn't you say that he's smarter
than his uh uh the UFC that's his
brother Bruce Buffer is his brother well
I thought it was his son no brother so
Bruce has to do a lot more work right
it's time and does announces everybody
but he doesn't all he says is let's get
ready to rumble and you know he's way
more and he uh copy wrote that yeah if
you do if you say you gotta pay him yeah
that's that's amazing yeah yeah and now
Bruce Buffer and uh Michael Buffer they
they didn't know they were brothers what
do you mean they drew Michael Buffer
doesn't know that he's Bruce buffers
they didn't know they were related to
their like me no because he's Bruce and
I'm Mike how the [__] can we be related
how does a mic how can Mike Buffer be
related to Bruce Buffer isn't that crazy
like as a childhood they didn't grow up
together and then he saw Mike on TV he
was like what the [__] yeah it looks
like buffer and he's like that sounds
like me too and then they connected and
now Bruce is his manager wow yeah it
does all his deals yeah want to tell you
about a hustler Bruce hustles man for
real oh not Mike
uh Mike just does the he's he's a he's
the one hit wonder what else did he do
let's get ready to rumble he's out what
else does Mike do he's done some
commercials and things he's been some
movies but brucea does like Bruce is on
Cameo like he shot a thing for me here
and he's like can you give me like 15
minutes I'm like what's going on I say I
can feel these Cameo he makes six
figures doing Cameo so many people like
if you're getting married he does like
the whole UFC intro for your mayor for
your wedding he does birthdays brilliant
yeah and then he has his whiskey
he does a lot of stuff man really great
dude you got your whiskey by the way
right yes
I didn't either
[Music]
great timing great delivery solid videos
but people and then they just call me an
idiot yeah yeah which is good yeah
that's what you want to meet other
people
it's relatable now bodu Jack is 39
fellas that's old yes yes especially how
long he's been doing it
would you feel any type of way if Jake
Paul wanted to like collab with you and
make you the main event he's the co-main
event or vice versa would you feel weird
about it
would you do it depends on on money on
the finances like how are we gonna do it
yeah if you're gonna make more money you
do it right that's how that matters yeah
especially with a good opponent no ego
just yeah it's gonna be big no matter
what yep that's how I see it
I think Jake we're gonna collab on Tick
Tock and you we'll do a dance let's do
this we do yeah oh I got one first you
got one just thinking about okay before
we leave today let's do it hi what's
your biggest tick tock dance video it's
you doing what whenever I anything thing
whenever I move people love it
Gloria Estefan said the same thing
my Hips Don't Lie
now this dude I fought over a year
this should be a gimme for Badoo right
you would think I'm thinking to give me
you were still going for tires I don't
think so I don't know
I'm thinking it's a gimme
though they definitely interested yeah
that was the guy
who was it I hope this fight he's so
famous that guy that they just seen who
was that dude oh
you got me I did not you got me if he
was that famous you would have knew
[Music]
you would hope this I think do you think
this is gonna go the I think I don't
think it was the distance no you think
it goes this no they set this fight up
on purpose because they want excitement
so you got two hard hitters it better be
excited I want this to end quick I'm
gonna say three runs I want to see the
fight I like your I think we're happy
yeah I'm gonna say under five definitely
not going all 12.
she's gonna throw it you're taking uh
yep the cabin three
oh man
three and uh next year in Jerusalem
[Laughter]
well that's a Passover standard
touching gloves
round one boom you know Adidas is
resigning Kanye he's coming back I saw
that no amazing that's not true
they were going to lose one point like
four billion dollars and they're like oh
this is a mistake and so now they're
bringing them back wow
that's really nice to share with two
Jews thank you well I just wanted you
guys to know before you I heard you I
saw you on your phone you're gonna buy
some uh Adidas I want to give you a
heads up
sticking out for you yeah man seeing if
you guys are wearing Adidas nope
the Space Jam 11's Adam we come with the
fire lately last night you wore these uh
Sean camps old school Sean Camp Space
Jam or uh NBA Jam uh Sean Kemps yeah
yeah these are fun
it's gotten the shoes in the last like
five years I'd say these adult my boy uh
the beat makes these
okay this guy's not actually a bad
fighter right yeah no both these guys
super talented
Canadian flag on his ass there Howie
that is
why where did he put it there why is
Canada there Prime spot
Prime real estate man all right I get it
that's uh Logan's Prime spot oh yeah
yeah let's go I'm selling the prime
I really like how about new Jack always
fits pressure I like how he gets
pressure
I don't think you're gonna win your bet
Adam
I don't think I am either
oh it doesn't look
kind of lopsided to me is it getting
more crowded there yeah that back row
still looks pretty empty it's so dark
though you can't tell people are there
for the main event
100 percent
yeah one thousand
foreign
you know he's beating up MMA guys like
oh he's inside a real boxer Tommy Fury
has no background MMA
but I I he's still not gonna get the
validation from the boxing fan base
because it's close Tommy Fury he's eight
no he's still kind of like not looked at
it as like a legit boxer right but he's
looked at as more formidable than
anybody he has sparked fought before
yeah who uh he's the most confident yeah
for sure who instigated this fight Jake
or Tommy they both they're kind of both
but I'm surprised that usually happens
probably Jake but I'm sure
and as soon as Jake I like this move
though by Jake to fight Tommy stylistic
perfect matchup for Jake perfect oh yeah
chance if you get knocked out not high
yeah Jake is really smart Jake hits hard
this guy comes from boxing royalty with
his brother being Tyson Fury the best
boxer on the planet right so there's so
many Pros for him is that usually how it
goes down where it's discussions have
been you know ongoing or is it literally
someone could call someone out on
Twitter and then things get in motion
you'll be a certain level yeah yeah like
if something up and coming called out
Ryan he's going to entertain it no but
if like Stevenson did or you know even
if they did it's like how often you're
challenged a lot a lot it's a lot like
once a week somebody says yeah I mean I
don't know I don't yeah probably yeah
maybe once a week especially anyone in
like any close to his weight class or
they're even coming up
because they want yeah they want to the
shot they want what you have to get
their names that's what it takes
hey Steven Seagal uh challenge you
he's in Russia he's too young don't know
oh [__] so kids today look it seems I
mean Fresca curling yeah
24. who's your Steven Seagal um
look at the DJ yeah Aquaman yeah there
you go what's a bummer I know something
when I was coming up was a badass like
his Under Siege movies like he was a
badass Beast Man now he's like kids look
at him like is that the whale was
totally he was he's kind of in a
Schwarzenegger uh that's crazy and he's
always been crazy remember they thought
he was fighting in the UK and Russian
war but it came out as just fake yeah
yeah so he was a cop for a while isn't
he a cop well he was a cop in New
Orleans and he got busted for a sex
trafficking ring what was that movie
with like Stallone Seagal Schwarzenegger
like last Cowboys or something like it
was all the old action stuff sounds
fantastic but I've never heard you know
what I'm talking about looking up right
now
Expendables Stephen Segal wasn't on
there yeah the dependables wait you were
way off no but they like Space Cowboys
Space Cowboy I think that's a movie too
but I would watch those guys uh fight to
the death right Stallone versus
Schwarzenegger now yeah now I would
wouldn't I don't see students who all
fight
if Jake Paul challenged Steven Seagal
I'm buying it
all right yeah
Buddy's Landing a little here come on
buddy Jack this is a little boring to me
it's the most technical fight we've had
and when it's Technical and they're
feeling each other out especially for 12
rounds the first few rounds when they
feel each other out get a little boring
they'll probably start opening oh that's
good oh probably start opening up by the
five six yes switch to 12 rounds it's
got them in agreeance usually
and Badoo likes when guys are getting a
little bit more tired that's when he
starts coming off as a fighter do you
plan if you're doing a long fight many
rounds you don't you don't want a
knockout in round one if it's there I'll
take it like if I you know see a good
shot I'm gonna for an experienced guy
I'd be tough to like they're usually not
going to come in too aggressive round
one especially a guy like Ryan with how
much so much power they're gonna wait
till the later rounds
but you know people can make mistakes
yeah I think and bring the pressure you
never know but if they want to get
froggy come on in yeah exactly I like
that yeah shorter night in the office
right let's do it
they're starting to open up a little
here
how many rounds is this one 12. 24
rounds 12 that's what sucks
there's no way it better not go 12 man
it can't I don't I don't see this guy
going 12. right the guy on the right
looks sleepy to me what's Jake thinking
about right now
probably trying to
talk to anybody or is he saying talking
to himself yeah sorting out his his
brother's dad's in there yeah I mean he
does a lot of meditation so he's
probably doing meditation
I assume for for
uh Jake Paul too like the bigger fish is
on the other side of this because
there's talk between him and Nate Diaz
wow but do you think that that's oh
that'd be incredible but that wouldn't
be in his mind right now no not right
now I'm just saying like this
guys yeah yeah whoever loses like we
said how a career is finished it's a lot
of pressure
and for Tom if you lose to this YouTuber
Disney kid and your brother's Tyson Fury
yeah how are you gonna go back home and
walk the Streets of London
you can't uh lose the Disney kid image
you can't ever right no never no matter
what he does I'm sure he doesn't like to
be referred to as the Disney kid this
one has tattoos and grew a beard is he
the only Disney kid that's ever um
yeah maybe 100 right even Stephen didn't
Shia LaBeouf
right I thought it was the booth how
about that but you also thought Space
Cowboys was a movie tomato that was my
soft pitch wouldn't it be great to see
all these guys together
on a range
did they even do that program anymore
that like young Disney program anymore
with those kids what is that yeah not a
sentence you should be saying out loud
Brian hey did they still do that thing
where they groom kids into the Disney
World uh what are you talking about like
the Disney Disney shows like just Justin
Timberlake was on there oh yeah yeah I
don't think they have the Mickey Mouse
Club but they do sitcoms basically a
sketch show for kids right it's kind of
what the Mickey Mouse Club was right
because then there is what can be with
them all that all that was the closest
probably there is actually one that just
there's one but then people come out of
the other shows like uh Ariana Grande
Ariana Grande yeah oh Sam and Cat
Mauritius on that show not Hargitay
heartsgrove um what are you saying
there's another Disney show um
I said Mariska Hargitay was a Disney kid
we're into heartsgrove that's who it is
iCarly wrote a book saying how much he
hated it yeah like despised it oh that
girl yeah on Disney
strawberries in order Blue Diamond
bullets yeah
I guess now too though especially a
talented kids that would go to Disney
and she can just go back to the YouTube
would you let your kids pop into the
Disney World if they were actors oh well
I don't know you know they're coming off
real evenly matched right yeah but I
think there's no real dominant you think
what I think the guy in the backup is
gonna break down
why what do you see that tells you that
he's going to break down his body
demeanor that shot
he doesn't have that right there what
just happened yeah he does his body his
body uh whatever he's showing like
macabo looks tired
the other one looks like he's gonna
break down yeah I think Jack's gonna
break down no no the guy in the black
black gloves he's gonna break down
junior shorts
I wish I could
yeah oh
open up oh
you need a good left hook when you're
fighting a softball it really helps how
many Jake Paul fans are watching this
just so frustrated that these two are
still yeah praying for because his fans
are like you know they're not real
boxing enthusiasts they're like dude if
we don't see Jake we're gonna [__]
they would much rather see some
streamers fighting right now yeah I was
gonna say how many of his fans have come
over to the boxing world that are
actually sticking around for like other
that they're now enthusiasts oh they're
like we can't wait to see right well
Ryan's different because I bet you 80 of
this pay I bet you 80 of this
pay-per-view audience is
are just followers yeah 100 not boxing
100 no yeah but that's good for the
sport that's what we were talking about
in the beginning
and hopefully it can make people fall in
love with the sport yeah one percent
stays that's one percent you wouldn't
have had do you plan uh your post game
um you know I don't do you have like
catchphrase or things you want to say
like you'd be like I'm the king the same
the same way yeah if you win an Academy
Award you got your speech are you like
all right if the the big match uh you
know goes down in the way I wanted to I
want to make sure to hit these things or
you kind of sometimes it comes to my
mind yeah and then I you know practice
see the way he goes back to the corner
he looks like he's not going to break
down I just I feel like though but yes
but his body posture I don't know how
he's doing it's kind of like kind of
sloppy and then I don't know this guy
looks real nervous to be interviewing
Mike it's radio that Chappelle's uh
security guy
oh it is yeah
who the guy his name's interview yeah I
know yeah I understand that yeah the
movie that uh yeah he goes by radio yeah
he goes by radio yeah is that the Cuba
Gooding uh Junior movies basically I
don't know if that's those things are
connect it could be yeah I don't know
maybe that's why I guess yeah he's got a
little Cuba smile right
again the back does not want to be on TV
yeah yeah
the interviewer interviewing Mike Tyson
has uh worked with Dave no but you're
saying the guy in the back that's the
guy in the back on the right who looks
like you don't want to be there
the guy's staring into the abyss oh my
God he's looking trying to see himself
on the screen no no no he's hating life
yeah it's kind of filling up now you're
right co-main event so this is you
called it this is four
let's do it macabo you think it's going
down here well that's what he called
didn't he
do these guys get a diarrhea belt too or
no
is there a belt on the line for this
chin is there a diarrhea belt too for
the Coleman event for a 12 rounds that
belt looks pretty lit has like jewels on
it and [__]
I feel like this should be a title fight
if it's 12 rounds usually 12 rounds our
title fight
don't give these guys the memos we're
all just waiting
yeah wrap it up fellas
I gotta pee so bad I'm not gonna pee oh
yeah I have a chance to become first let
me hold on you have to win the World
title we'll get a sink in here for you
or
don't tell me you're gonna pee you get
you leave don't say you're gonna pee
then that's peer pressure I put pressure
on you high a little bit do you get
performance anxiety when at the urinal
Howie
you know I once did people at a urinal
after a movie there's oh my God I don't
know what you're gonna say I go right in
between so they can't move there's no
urinal and just piss on the wall
what are you doing
this is not a bad fight this is actually
a really good fight don't you think yeah
it's picking up steam too it's picking
up steam it's a little more boring but
the better the fight the more boring it
is
watching technique yeah
the Cowboys got a minute 10 to earn me
16 bucks
I mean it was more exciting to watch zit
oh
I don't know where that happened is that
that was the right hand right that was
that was that was a nice shot
got right back up there we go all right
you might right back up yeah you felt
that one it's a nice little tumble
though
wow that was a great shot right timed
him right now in a minute
oh he's hitting him now now Jack's fired
up after that right right he's caving
you were right I just felt it right so
what happens if the opponent goes down
like that you're just now you're just in
kill mode right I mean you're obviously
wanting to go for it but you got to be
careful sometimes the hurt fighter is a
dangerous fighter I like that
that happened to Anthony Joshua remember
oh you dropped oh yeah he ran in there
and got knocked out
hurt fighter is a dangerous fighter yes
but his Focus has to be off yeah 100 but
then you then if you go in there
thinking that you know I could get him
right now you might run into one
yourself
boy he's got a
fast Jab
oh that guy
can you tell he's shaky yep who's that
look at this right hand oh nice he goes
that's it yeah also tricked him I don't
know if you saw the feet that's what
really made him go down watch this
he gets Tangled in the uh watch right
here see boom
yeah
he was stepping on his foot too
go for it right what if we all go to the
restroom please guys I got a monologue
I'd love to work through
all right they're gone
welcome back to two Jews breakdown
boxing hi madam Ray I'm Howie Mandel
yeah and uh Shabbat Shalom and also uh
who's the audience we're gonna lose an
audience
this had a lot of people watching live
and now it's no it's grown it's still
grown really it's over 8 000 now you're
over 8 000. my viewers
um Howie Mandel does stuff is the
podcast and about last night is my book
subscribe right now let's see how many
of these people subscribe subscribe
right now right now subscribe to the
guys
I'm on the road adamraycomedy.com for
all my tickets and tour dates coming up
and going to Phoenix West Palm Beach
Seattle Portland uh uh Texas dell.com is
where you can get my merch go to get the
merch he's got butt plugs and hoodies
and they walk out the two Jews start
selling yeah it just writes itself
laughs
anyway let's back to the fight back to
the fight and Jack 220. then you have
him out at three or four I did I did
thanks for bringing it up let's talk
about my parents divorce next 216 left
in the fifth round
not 11 zits on these guys
clean bags Open Hearts clear heads
see if he rocks them
somebody called five somebody called
five somebody did call five did somebody
call five did somebody call five
remember I think who called five Brendan
I think he called five yeah welcome back
to the show Brian shops this is it we're
in your round we gotta run baby
less than two minutes left to figure out
whether you know what you're talking
about or not
oh that's trying to exchange here a
little bit yeah come on boys
this is actually a really good fight
yeah it is the first good fight of the
oh who got knocked down
another dude not Badu
makabu how do you say the guy uh yeah
yeah
you gotta write yeah oh I like macaboo
macaboo's cool
Abu sounds like something you get in
your trick or treat bag and your parents
like I don't know if I'd eat that or not
Fubar mom yeah it's it's a fentanyl
KitKat
[Applause]
whoa
you knock him down oh come on oh [__]
oh
Jackson live through that
on his feet
yeah he's hunching
he hits him all the time against his
little body uppercuts
there you go there you go
35 seconds Brennan to uh who got hurt we
have one knock down you were here for
The Knockout
so they actually took a break right and
they said yo let's just talk about this
you know why are we so angry and then
they sat down
um yeah and they started hugging yeah
here we go oh there's five it's gonna
end
we're going into round six come on
fellas come on Badoo 10 seconds that
guy's done
left hook
boom a couple more hits on Michael I
think he's done yeah oh he's wobbly too
he's like he's been wobbly for two
rounds now
I did afford them wow that shot did
affect them even though it looked like
look look he just stepped back you can't
even yeah it's not a huge arena is it it
doesn't look like it there you go you
were asking what he's doing
there you go
talking to his dad
just trying to stay hyped right I mean
you don't get too hype you don't want to
waste the energy in the locker right
you're not burning cows just pacing
nervously
not even nervous looking at me so
[__] poised he's ready
see you can't have big muscles
Tommy's upper body like your shoulders
and arms are huge it just slows you down
it's built like a stingray really
like a stingray most big hitters don't
have um
don't have like a
I don't have a big muscle so it may slow
you down but doesn't it add to the force
of the hit
not for him yeah I don't think he's not
a not good artist I think it messes up
the delivery on the shot
personally that's what I think remember
back in the day boxers used to think
lifting weights would yeah make you too
muscly and I I lift weights but not that
type of weights
he's listening he's doing for the gram
too he makes a lot of money on Instagram
posting his shirt and stuff
shirtless shirtless yeah
with some traps on it yeah
I have to like Jake would knock this guy
out yes I agree
I don't get how they do it on the love
Island show those boys just stay ripped
and the girls just I mean that's their
life entire show man
what's the premise of Love uh Island
it's like uh I don't know 10 girls 10
boys it's easy I do kegel exercises that
makes sense are you still going to
Curves
no they closed it but now I just at home
I'll do kegel exercises and I'm not
going to show you now but I have uh I
have a sick sack prove it
prove it
I didn't use my manscape but I have a
six six ripped it's ripped
it's all talk huh
all right come on Bottle Jack come on
all right it's time wow there you go
don't go 12. no please don't go 12 I
don't ask for much but
I Know Jack looks like he's tiring too a
little yeah now it kind of Rights he
didn't pick it up he's backing up
usually has a great Pace he's also 39
yeah how old's the other guy 37 14.
uh Ryan I think that's one of the issues
with boxes like the undercards no one
Stacks them like the UFC yeah dude like
the UFC next week uh on March 4th Jon
Jones fight fire stacked isn't Israel on
that he's not on that one he's on a
later one but uh that one's you have
chefchenko on there you have a bow
nickel on there like huge Stars So when
you buy a paper you get your money's
worth in boxing like you're literally
just paying for the main event why is
that
Fox's model but it's also why Ryan gets
all the money yeah that's why Ryan and
scheduling two right like for those UFC
fights like if they can get these guys
to you know come together in those dates
but it really is just money right Money
Talks what's the purse for your fight
uh uh
no I don't I don't I don't know hey what
are your turn-ons and turn on yeah I
know it's a lot of money like what's a
lot I know over well you don't have to
tell us again no hold on but a lot of
times not a lot of money how about this
how much you get for the fight and how
much you're getting for season uh this
next season of AGT oh what's up now how
you feel okay I just have to be the
exact number give us like two two uh ten
all right 10 to 20. I'll tell you wow
and that could be more thousands
you can make ten thousand dollars on
your next fight yes that's why I'm doing
it yeah [__] I could buy so many good
things
can't get a Hummer that's like almost
100 I make in French
but then sometimes we do extra like when
you pick the golden buzzer guy yeah wow
that makes sense you got bonuses
so Ryan when you see like Jake Paul he's
on Forbes top top like fighter earners I
think it was like I don't know is he
second or third like Connor from his
whiskey was still number one but Jake I
think it was like third at like 40
million yeah for you big dogs out there
like you're like yeah that's what we
make right yeah like we fought twice if
you fight often you should make okay on
that yeah if you're review a top fighter
yeah your big name if you're not that's
what people don't understand so are you
good with your money are you investing
uh learning a lot about that you have a
good person that tells you I think so
it's not your awesome uncle is it it is
no that's all right I'm learning yeah
you're buying real estate yes that's the
most
that is the most what's five
five what come on boys get each other
out of there
this guy looks very mad yes and he's
punching right now
he's an angry face
I know
I do because I can see a big shot for
this you think he looks madder or do you
think his eyebrows are so swollen he's
got that scallop a little bit of both
swelling yeah all right new prediction
macaboo and eight or Jack and 10. Jack
in 10.
although macabre's really coming on
strong yeah it's a lot of Bodywork I
know surprising
because he looked like he already faded
one of those rounds
got some new energy yeah I think it's
interesting how how now maybe you guys
know this a lot of the public doesn't
understand it so there's a lot of talk
about fighter pay when it comes to UFC
yeah it's like the biggest knock on Dana
like fighter pay fighter pay oh of
course you know on average UFC fighters
make more money than boxers like the the
top like one percent of boxers like Ryan
and these other guys make all the money
yeah the rest of them make nothing like
the guys you're seeing these guys might
make some but the people before that
these two guys make oh man Jake because
the Jake it's a jake promotion he takes
care of the guys yeah bottle jacks yeah
probably about two 200.
but in general how many of those two
hundred thousand dollar fights do they
have a year not many wow it's usually
it's a majority of the no there's not a
lot of like yeah it's a rare kind of for
these guys to probably make that I'm not
saying that makes it right UFC should
pay more they pay at like 70 of their
own kind of like affecting you know in
comedy most of the comedians aren't
making a lot of money yes there you go
but a lot of the early matches on the
UFC but the great thing is well yeah
you're gonna make a bunch of money it's
handsomely like you'll make a living
doing it yeah but you have no benefits
like you probably could make more you
know I don't if you're on the prelims
you know maybe you're at 12 and 12. so
is Dana kind of turned the ship around
on this or is it still coming he doesn't
turn the ship around but I used to
criticize him all the time before but at
the end of the day it's like it's not
his job for the fighters are you guys
trying to unionize yeah yeah yeah I was
part of that it was a nightmare it's
like wrangling cats because the the Big
Dog's like wait whoa don't change this
we're making all the money it's like I
know but it's not about you right now
it's about the future Fighters and the
guys can make an actual change like
we're good man and also if you're Dana
it's like with apple like yeah they
could probably make them in America and
cost them more money but they're like
why would we yeah for Danny's like why
would I change it
what do you want me to do
it's tough man it's a fight business
it's not and he knows people aren't
going to stop watching right I mean it's
not like you're gonna stop using an
iPhone yeah you can stop driving a Tesla
prices at sporting events but right what
are you gonna not go I mean we're gonna
stop making eggs you're crazy
so is that guy doing good Macaba
who's winning I don't think he's winning
I know Badoo is winning but
it's tough yeah that macabre's the
now Problem Child how old is he at some
point you just be the problem right
yeah it's also great that's become the
problem he should be wearing a shirt of
that kid in the problem child that movie
he's 26. you hit 30. we got to ditch the
child
you're just the problem man problem man
the problem ain't no problem man
the problem adult problem problem or
childlike you just add child life the
problem child like yeah I'm childlike
there's a fighter called Wonder Boy
Thompson he's 38 years old I call him
wonder man yeah
Wonder Man sick I think problem man is
great too
now they moved uh what Puerto Rico
Puerto Rico and he set up a facility in
Puerto Rico that's to die for that you
know when I talk to him I can't believe
he's still in L.A the taxes I'm like I
don't want to move to Puerto Rico dude
get what you pay for you stay there for
a certain amount of time though six
months does anybody have the nickname
The Shadow
I think that'd be cool you do know
foreskin or the uh the anteater the
anteater that's not bad the Wizards the
Wizards the the Wizards if you live in
Puerto Rico you don't pay taxes yeah
they don't have uh state taxes or you
know so he pays no
this guy I'm sure you can't get around
all of it you know
that's why they went to Puerto Rico for
the taxes
when we're like really locked down they
got out of here never heard I get it
nice Ahmad Le Bond yeah the shadow Labon
great name decent record too thirteen
and five yeah it's decent the shadow
would be a great name yeah
I like the anteater
flows I wouldn't want to face you would
want to face him or uh sit in an Uber
with him boy we've just been given
Fighters nicknames call that one zits
zits Martinez oh yeah he's gonna hate
hearing this princess the princess got
some pop to it yeah
how would you have nicknames no but but
the no but the princess would be a good
like even if you were really great you
see you should change from the King to
the princess because when you win yes it
feels so much work you know what [__]
knocked me out the [__] princess Ryan
the princess I got knocked out by the
[__] [__] princess sure or what about
the queen
right silly
come on that's why I like you draw the
line right yeah I mean
you can do too much yeah too silly yeah
the queen that's the princess was
usually my go-to in uh Mario uh uh Mario
too
princess I just I just beat the brakes
off my son right but I was almost late
because we just got Mario Kart on
Nintendo switch we put on the big did
you take him to the universal they
opened up that hole is it open Mario
World open my son went and said it was
[__] oh he's gonna freak out I didn't
know that oh we're definitely going yeah
but we got the Nintendo switch and we
put it you know the theater so we
connect to the theater and we're playing
Mario Kart I'm like you have no idea how
cool this is it's all that's all he
knows I'm like me and your Uncle Jay
who's just over I'm like yeah we played
on a tiny little screen wow spoiled yeah
he's like shut up yeah I was like shut
up like an old guy when I was up I know
I do I'm not gay right now that's his
go-to game Royal car Mario Kart we
didn't even have one smash we didn't
have Nintendo wait I just had a friend
named Mario and he used to have to jump
over [__]
the problem because you I'm assuming you
grew up playing video games as a kid
yeah my mom would let me get those I
mean yeah dude single mom Power jobs
yeah we played I mean School Contra my
mom let me buy Super Nintendo with my
bar mitzvah money uh but only if I
because she was afraid wasn't gonna make
me do my homework so I had to go to my
buddy's place who had every system he
had a Sega he had [__] Sega Saturn 12
rounds bad parents yeah about a Sega
Saturn you got it I came with like 19
votes really associating tired equally
as tired I had a 3DS guys and a Jaguar
they both won't give up it's just a
tired fight now it used to look good now
it's just tired still going with Cabo
Big Shot talking
there's a there's a dope game on that uh
Nintendo switch out for now Luigi's
Mansion 3.
damn it's a good game would you be an
adult game I mean I guess
Luigi's Mansion it's all about Luigi's a
haunted house yeah it's like a mystery
and you got to find stuff based on a
true start Luigi hit it big when he
broke off from Mario huh Luigi broke off
yeah the band broke you're holding me
back yeah yeah I think that I think that
was the count but yeah I think that was
it yeah
wait what what happens in Luigi's
Mansion where you got to uh solve the oh
uh Mario gets kidnapped wow
great stories anyway if that was the
same amount the new Mario landed
in Luigi it's like Jason
like taken but missing two gay brothers
yeah it's taking me it's brokeback so
that's going to be engaged retirement
but then kidnapped that's what I was
like meaning he was doing and then when
he brings him back finds out that he's
actually married with a family and a
wife yeah you got a princess new energy
list because there's Yoshi they're
illegitimate kids
beat down before the other now they both
look they're both like kind of fading
this thing's really so my new it's gonna
be 12 rounds and it's gonna be a
decision oh it's gonna be
put him down which Butter's not really
throwing the heat like he doesn't have
bad intentions
he's tired
no you didn't train for this maybe
you're just like whatever yeah
how how soon
how when do you stop sparring before a
big fight usually it's like a week a
week yeah
Ryan have you ever had a fight I've had
this happen while I was bringing like
really good training partners and I got
clipped and then it was like a week out
from a fight and I remember in hindsight
I wish my coaching like not smart don't
fight like oh you'd be fine you got your
bell run this is before CT that's how
old I am so I remember going into the
fight being like Oh I should be okay but
I remember so I had like concussion like
symptoms and then you see I get clipped
with a punt that usually I could take
finish the fight oh man no have you been
clipped in trading or know that no not
not to the point where I I thought I had
a concussion yeah but I've gotten buzzed
like oh [__] yeah but
no have you been um hurt like that and I
probably wouldn't if I if I if I yeah no
now the fighter is much more smarter
yeah that guy's like yeah yeah you build
on you're fine it's like okay that makes
sense yeah that's literally out like
knocked out
I hit you with a lucky shot champ yeah
you'll be fine it won't happen in the
fight
oh
did you guys watch the uh Lamar Odom
Aaron Carter uh match no no I'm not that
big of a loser
chin
I did because for current events I had
to watch sure yeah yeah it was just a
nightmare it was terrible it was
terribly bad yeah I mean just the size
difference alone was just seven foot
yeah and then Aaron Carter was just
swinging like a kid trying to get you're
seeing money and then it's a shame right
because he passed away so clearly the
guy's struggling yeah
people ask me like are you doing any
little celebrity fights go listen if you
see me fight Lamar Odom or Mario Lopez
business is not going well although but
you can watch shop Lopez
it's the equivalent of Dancing With the
Stars yeah yeah yes business is not
booming
can you imagine though if you give them
what 10 mil to do shop Lopez you'd do it
very easy night in the office yeah yeah
and I'd promote my tour dates working
out yes and during the fight like the
camera
Oklahoma City next weekend Brea March
4th
here we go who's there you go come on
get him out of that play the pressure
man finish
that rocked him
it's a shame the round was over because
I got him
he needed one more man cry
boom
you're not gonna hit a guy with a better
oh that sat him down yeah I agree
where am I he's not looking at any
that's a shame there was a more time
left because he could have done some
damage there
right over the top
boom boom yeah he landed some good ones
too got his Pace isn't oh yeah he's his
leg Yeah
yeah he was hurt
man I mean how do you stay up on your
feet
I don't see him Landing a better shot
than that he had everything into it
he if he had more time maybe he could
have finished him off
again he's a fires Barber I think a live
DJ who is that
uh we'll try to look it up hold on let
me see again the second lead in the
kitchen right here
until we figure out who that is
if anyone on the live chat can just say
the girl on the two girls one cup has
never gotten anybody on the live chat
the live chat we're live we're live here
oh yeah yeah tell us who the DJ is if
he's a DJ yeah it looks like DJ Spivak
or whatever her name is you still say
that
sound sound like some sort of a slur
Paige Spivak what is that you know what
I'm talking about who is that yeah you
don't know she's like I'll look into
that golfer she's like I think she was
labeled like the hottest girl in the
world wow you don't look at that stuff
you're married now I get it no I just
yeah when I get it not a golf guy
's girlfriend
boxing sexist ring girls you won't see
it Tommy well what if you won't see it
Tommy fear okay well we don't want to
see him here
um
type in the DJ for Jake Paul I did but
why can't you tell us people they're
watching they're telling us but they're
they're giving us really [__] up
things yeah
I don't think so okay he's hurt
oh he's super hurt yeah she's flying on
the Rogues come on
what hurts more a nut Punch or a gut
punch
it's the right place is good yeah
yeah nothing like your body a liver he's
known for the liver shot
got my last one over there too
did that guy go to the hospital no no he
got dropped two more times after it but
come on makaboo
oh he's got he's tough that's what I say
like God damn this dude will not you're
just getting like Craig when you go
through a fight like that the next
morning oh you're hurt it's got to be
hard to sit up
you just took out ran frantically he's
out you go to a bathroom that bad bro
laughs
oh
they're trading them here
are these is this chair real leather
I think so if it's vinyl I just gonna I
don't I'm gonna piss off
do it man okay I'm gonna piss at least
I'm gonna do it's hard okay okay
oh
yeah
oh it's there it's been there you feel
like he's right on that I know get him
out of there but then but then there's
only 10 seconds left come on 12 seconds
come on you got it boom no
he's tired
it's frustrating they're both they're
both Landing
yeah that guy has heart man
he's Landing a lot of hits
jeez
he loves character
in the in the corner he looks like he's
much more together
boom
oh that's the one I was looking for chin
what time is it over there in uh Saudi
Arabia right now
it's like 1am 1 or 2 A.M let's see late
oops
it's very strange they say doing uh
Saudi Arabia I know it's for Tommy
Fury's corner so you can get in damn
it's 12 45 a.m over there and yep
so the DJ's Havana Brown DJ Havana Brown
DJ Havana Brown yeah I told you I told
you you did you got it internet wrong
again not dj [__] be cool man
yeah DJ Celestia
it's not a fire yeah it's kind of dope
it's weird having a DJ though huh
is it she's pretty though a little bit
oh oh
come on no you'll make the eight count
and then finish him off here
for Havana Brown look at this guy's face
look at the do it for a DJ [__] man
you do anything come on dude Havana
Brown's cool
finishing she's Australian finish finish
oh he's laying a little bit too though
God he is like how how much dude give
him a smooch on the cheek bite his ear
and call it a day dude
okay
foreign
get ready for my prediction yeah
oh
don't put him a headlock you can't do
that
come on come on
this guy's not doing well uppercuts
there huh
nah he's not he's finished
that's fighting I sure will now yeah
they should be stuck it's weird because
I seen that though like earlier but his
dude came back right but you don't think
he should be stopping it that's not I
mean yeah I mean I should have done it
already no but I'm talking about the ref
that guy doesn't oh come on do you think
the ref should stop this now his Corner
would stop it I think a corn stop is
more likely like uh you're not gonna win
this you're just taking punishment for
no reason but maybe they're like just
what he does that's
how he's walking he's so wobbly yeah
come on guys that's me man this will
help him get fights though if he could
keep yeah if he stops they're gonna be
pissed yeah
okay almost less than a minute and a
half from my prediction ladies and
gentlemen
anticipation stay tuned first
prediction yeah that's that's that game
show teaser how he's so good at that
right coming up don't go anywhere don't
go anywhere
two minutes ten seconds from my
prediction I just saw a flash of how he
was dead you know like coming up me
coming in two minutes don't go anywhere
there we go
two minutes away
come on watch it I think I don't know
this game what do you really think is
gonna happen I think I don't know you
don't think I know boxing
I remember I can't believe this one
this one too tough yeah well first of
all I'll make part of it I think it's
gonna go 12 rounds yeah but I'm not okay
you need all the info until it's time
yeah you don't make predictions without
the info without that somebody famous
said that
how many nutshots could you take right
before truly it's you know you're done
you're too numb
he's asking for a friend
[Laughter]
I could take about
four five that's a lot a lot during the
sixth grade somebody threw a basketball
and it hit me right
because that was done for the week
what's that are you talking about with
the cup on in a fight are you talking
about straight up nut shot I'm just
straight up nutshot oh no you're having
me let's say you're at the Grove okay
go to Banana Republic right like I could
use a new uh you know jacket of some
sort maybe a bomber maybe chinos maybe
some chinos and uh some kids walk by
some YouTube kids right trying to get
their page going and they're like yo
Ryan Garcia let's see how many yo I'm
here yo hey
how many nut shots can you take before
you know I'm crazy and dude
Minecraft so you can take today that you
answer me I could take four yeah four I
could take four times
just estimating here yeah
that's impressive there's nothing worse
than hit in the nuts when you're a kid
it's so embarrassing oh dude the
numbness you feel from top to bottom
I've been known to take good nut shots
though that's your thing that's your
Niche it says
four nut shots exactly
King nutshots yeah Nutcracker
whoa oh this guy has been wrong that's
it go down
oh my God yeah
so I say the 12th round a minute into
the 12th round that feels right that's
my prediction
yo
crushed it though man my fighter he
stayed in there nobody knows boxing
better than you no
no the 12th round predictor yeah he's
like Mickey from Rocky he just knows
everything yeah yeah
people don't know what I know what's up
but I don't make willy-nilly predictions
without no expert man info that's a
great fight Adam this made me think you
guys watching a thing because I watched
that whale movie back to whale with
Kevin Frazier and he was in makeup for
14 hours yeah how long were you gonna
make up to be Jay Leno four and a half
is a while but yeah that's crazy 14
hours yeah how about that cowboy movie
instant development it's in development
let's pitch that again man you play play
your cards right you can get a little
Cameo on that he's been hitting this guy
with this shot the whole time I did uh
four hours of makeup for a little money
I was just gonna ask yeah
what do you do just sit there I mean I
glued [__] latex I feel like such a
dick yeah covered in latex I was like no
I that's why I would never wear a copy
after that movie no more I said I'm not
doing this to my dick now I know what my
dick felt yeah
now the I think the longest in makeup is
Jim Carrey when to hit the Grinch oh my
God it was something like that that's
intense you have to bring it you have to
bring in a mental coach yeah he's about
to freak out oh yeah oh look I have zits
I could have been a boxer could have
been Martinez Martinez how many days
shoot with that uh in makeup Howie three
months in in every day uh North Carolina
wow in middle of August wow
every day great movie Man that'd be
horrible horrible no it's one of the
best after that
and I turned down every other offer
after are you serious yeah I turned on
some big movies how was Fred Savage to
work with oh it was great it was a kid
then you know he had just come off The
Princess Bride oh my God you know and
that was pretty Wonder Years right no
wonder years was there he was doing
Wonder Years princess on top of the
world wizard remember the movie Wizard
where him and his brother uh yeah yeah
Waverly Place wizard Waverly Place oh
he's got a reference wow yeah close I
close Fred Savage and his brother uh his
brother like I think their mom dies and
he they wants to he's a video game freak
so they go on a road trip to this big
like Super Mario 3 you know uh
competition and uh they basically run
away from home and hitchhike to get
there so it's a road trip movie and then
his dad is his older brother is
Christian Slater and his dad is Beau
Bridges I think and they go on the
lookout to try to bring him back but
then yeah it's incredible it's a kid
road trip Runaway movie right I'll tell
you what that movie was missing was uh
some Kratom from Happy HIPAA listen if
you're looking for the best Kratom on
planet Earth go to happyhippo.com promo
code is thick with three C's thick
t-h-i-c-c-30 it's the only Kratom I've
trust I've tried all of them it's the
only Kratom I will use I'll use it right
before I did this show this is their
Butterscotch the it's their High
concentrated shot of Kratom it's the
best craving on the planet you get three
percent off when you go to
happyhippo.com promo code is thick
actually I think it's thick 23 right is
it thick 23 the 30 was just a special
promo cool it's thick 23. t h i c c 23
for 20 off for Life share it with your
friends share whoever you want you get
the best Kratom you have gummies powders
tablets they got freaking the
concentrate shots that I use for every
freaking show that's Happy hippo.com
promo code is thick23. let's get back to
programming uh Fred Savage was great
that moves great Howie I can't believe
it it's no burdemic burdemic is one of
my favorite movies of all time what is
it bird demick look it up who's in that
clip from that I don't know the actors
names but I've seen it like 38 times
just play uh
that's what I watch all the time it's a
horror movie yeah just to play a clip
from it you'll you'll you'll go crazy
trailer yeah oh yeah it's just for us
though what it's just for us what do you
mean it's just for us we can't put it on
yet we can't put it on okay okay we
could play it for us and we could talk
about what we're seeing yeah yeah can
you see the sign tell me if this is
correct do you know this movie no yeah
this is yeah this is it this is it but
you can't is there like a Sharknado
oh okay but so this guy he's from Fast
Fierce yeah yeah and he's uh he he's uh
two white guys playing basketball right
but and then he meets the girl of his
dreams that's the girl of his Dreams
yeah and he starts taking pictures of
her and stuff like that because he's a
model and then they go out and then the
town before you know Watch What Happens
so it starts with love
and romance and now
this is the best part
they're out you think things are going
good yeah they're having a good time
it's a new beginning it's a new
beginning and then they're going to a
motel
and then birds take over huh birds take
over birds take over the town and really
wait till you see this it is the
scariest pigeons or no it's uh it's a
new breed of Terror
look at what happens wait till you see
the special effects
from it's a Visionary it's a yeah watch
it's this is pre-coveted and they're
wearing masks they find a dead bird it's
a romantic Thriller he's a master of
this wait till you see the birds that's
what I'm waiting for everybody's trying
to leave town
he knows something's up and the only way
to defend yourself against what's
happening is with hangers watch this
they realize the birds are there see
that
they're terrified the birds are trying
to attack everybody yeah they're there
oh man look at them look at this oh my
God look at the special effects things
are blown up now they get to go out with
the hangers hangers are the only thing
that kills the birds look at them
you got to watch this I'd rather deal
with those birds than the real coven
holy [__] it's amazing birdemic that's
my recommendation
I thought the movie looks so bad yeah I
thought it was going this way there's
like the Showgirls of bird Killer movies
right now
me too so this is the show Girls thank
you of course no it is you've got to
watch it with a friend
you've got shrooms what do you think the
budget for the bird uh you know
oh you're going way high yeah
oh it was it was a title yeah right yeah
we couldn't find out what exactly
wouldn't it be what his hat says WBC
champion WBC yeah he said I have a
chance to become a world champion the
first Muslim world champion
but I know exactly what the title was
yeah all right Main Event come on get
him out of there
so what is your prediction for this
uh I'll take Jake Paul in under four
rounds dang Jake and six
Jake and yeah probably
seventh round Jake seven oh if you one
dollar me prices and I'll tell you my
prediction in about a half an hour
[Laughter]
I'm Howie Mandela and I approve this
message
all right let's get them out of there
is that hard to sit that long though and
wait or that's why you said that they
tell you when you're gonna be that's
just a lot of waiting it is
I don't like getting into the arena too
early yeah that's what the anxiety like
all the pressure you're just sitting
back there waiting but you got to be
there right and this is his promotion so
he's got to be there the whole time I
don't know people come at different
times though he'll have like set time
I'll be there at 5 30 right oh they've
been showing him in the dressing room
for the last hour or maybe or they're
using Holograms how big is your
entourage pre-fight it's not not big he
just walks out with me yes me Howie
Mandel and your uncle and then
dick shop yeah I'm there
you gotta figure that they're gonna roll
out Paul and fury pretty fast here
because that fight with the decision the
card's been going on it wasn't supposed
to they were maybe hoping four or five
for that it went 12 but not decision oh
yeah that's right it went all 12 12 at
203. that's a great fight though good
fight I got hung in there for the
audience yeah I mean this especially
this audience in Jake Paul's fan base
they want Knockouts but yeah
let's knock out uh that everybody talked
about was what you think in boxing yeah
but the longer you can hold the eyes
but like we're talking about now it
looks full sure yeah yeah now it filled
in everybody's coming in now yeah oh
there she is there she is
um
I guess then you know whatever then
maybe one that you wrote yeah
it's probably all subjective if there's
a huge iconic one but
that was impressive I guess that's going
to be the truth this is the truth this
is the truth the truth what is the name
of your uh do you have a name for your
of your fight I don't know somebody's o
has got to go somebody's coming up
they're both undefeated well you don't
do that yeah
the truth I like it what's your
opponent's nickname you're the king tank
he's a little tank
King versus the tank I'm trying to think
knockout like I'm so good I'm about to
knock that question there's some
heavyweights like Anthony Joshua
[Music]
um
Fury
usik had some great fights against
Anthony Joshua he didn't knock him out
but who had a knockout that you were
like wow I know it's probably Fury right
what 12th round I'm actually gonna go to
the bathroom you're talking about with
Deontay Wilder yeah that was like a
crazy knockout then he just came up I
think how long ago that was though too
there's been some good like when uh tank
knocked out uh homeboy Leo Santa Cruz
yeah Santa Cruz that was vicious
yeah that was great too
that one was nasty that was nasty but
nobody even seen that company no because
it was like it looked like it was like a
pretty competitive yeah and then boom
that uppercut was filthy
yeah there hasn't been any crazy
knockouts
uh I'm gonna have to bounce in a few I'm
missing the main event yeah I will blame
it on this promotion yeah I know 12
rounds was uh
throw these auditions on tape and get to
the airport oh yeah were you headed to
Dallas Dallas for corporate tomorrow
yeah oh you're serious you're leaving
yeah
he's like oh you got [__] to do I
couldn't tell yeah uh it sucks you've
stayed here for just these kind of no
it's been fun totally worth it wouldn't
change so much fun
I had a blast yeah thanks for having me
you have to leave during the main event
I know that's what I'm trying to stick
around for at least the intro or one uh
one round you know yeah yeah stick
around for one round yeah okay
your flights over time flights is 6 30.
okay quickly pack but I gotta I gotta I
don't want to give myself like 20
minutes to do these ones I want to get
like at least 45 big auditions yeah that
was known too that fight yeah so when he
knocked out there's a list here let's
see another one that's Caleb plant yeah
what are people saying online chin about
like
I didn't look comments about like who
people think's gonna win so that's true
Cordina versus they're not stuff because
the internet hates Jake Paul you know so
I'm sure the narrative Islanders laywood
versus I think like knocked the guy out
in the last round and knock them out of
the ring wood yeah
so yeah Ryan knows all these Fighters
keep going chin that's it that's number
one well that's number one yeah they
don't have like a list of topics it was
the top it was the top five five or
something yeah let me see who else is on
the list
this is the fifth one
um
Ramirez all right keep going
by the way do you know this guy yes
right he's bad yeah right he's he's
super badass he's not known enough but
yeah yeah I guess no need to Denair
who's very popular
yeah Kayla plants knockout was filthy
Caleb plant fights soon too
he's fighting David Benavides I think
yeah welcome to the club dude
my bathroom in this thing oh yeah
there's a golden jacket waiting for you
when you walk out yeah I [__] I actually
you shouldn't have said I shouldn't say
okay
you're on my new prank show [__] sync
you just [__] and someone's thinking oh
gotcha all right thanks picture just
comes out past your Impractical Jokers
not a joke
is so weird it's weird to sit up on the
counter like that because the uh
so hard the faucet is cold it's like a
day for you what the faucet's like a
little bidet for you yeah what I tried
to do is turn the soap dispenser good
move good move
okay it's all good it's all good it's
all good it's all good why'd you go [__]
why'd you say because I heard loud
it's all good time I was just talking
about [__] man it's all good
yeah it has nowhere to go
man if they don't roll out Jake Paul
soon because Adam has to do some
auditions
yeah I didn't realize I mean we probably
could have started this companion at one
yeah
I got to get off a plane I'm sorry I ran
here in hindsight but news Ryan's
starving
been fasting since what's gonna be your
move what's the first thing you eat
right Evan I thought the main event was
going to be at 11. I don't know you
don't know I don't know I got to get
back to my my Camp house two o'clock
he's gotta eat
no just
I mean we're gonna bring out the sink
you're gonna eat my [__] I mean you're
walking out with you exactly I gotta get
to know you better
I do love watching a fight with you guys
it's fun I don't I don't want to watch a
fight without you guys know oh thank you
oh my God you're trying to make me cry
you want to leave her I just how dare
you where are you going Adam yeah put
some auditions on tape and then go do a
corporate desk
call them you get the job really yeah
wow so you're flying to Dallas tonight
yeah
this is tomorrow corporate gig those can
be dicey no this one's gonna be really
fun pays great it's a kid's amazing oh
no no I've talked to a handful of people
I mean the last two I've done have been
yeah like [__] shows have they um in a
in a you know I don't know a fun way but
just not uh have you done corporate gigs
because you won last night
you've got to embrace the diciness of
this they call you're a surprise
they don't know you're here sure and you
may want to mention the vice president
of the company's golf game yeah talk
about how Mark can't keep it in his
pants right yeah Marcus there's so many
Affairs Mark yeah Mark you can't keep it
in your pants
he goes [__] you get off the stage
yeah I'll give you a deal [__] off
you're like okay talk about the vice
president like I'm watching Kitty porn
one time okay yeah I think that's
something you should bring comedy's hard
enough as it is yeah when people go to a
comedy club or a theater they're ready
to watch but when you are let the the I
did a corporate gig in in Florida it was
for the Grocers Association and it's
where all the people from all the
islands they come to uh to buy their
their produce for their little stores in
Trinidad and that's what they were all
there and they had me as the as the
entertainment and I would say 85 percent
of room did not speak English
which is a prerequisite for most of your
shows yeah most of what I do yeah it's a
lot of gestures and faces I got
something last did you well I laughed
you can have a good time regardless yeah
they always say if you could make one
person laugh you're doing your job it
shouldn't be you yeah
here we go
he's doing interviews can we hear what
he's saying or no is that how you're
right Problem Child in Arabic I think
that's what he did yeah I think so it
was a little high tell us what he said
yeah he looks High tell us what he's
doing we can't hear it no if I didn't
take it high right it looks like towie
from South Park
yeah it does look high yeah he does
right I'm so high right now
so that's what Georgie said he's putting
on a show for the Saudi Arabians not
very excited yeah I'm sorry for the four
of us God damn for us yeah
all right I'm gonna work my heartless
you know try allowed to fight a little
box that's a lot of sandwiches turkey my
favorite
but you don't have to do it for fans
Logan and my brother threw all the way
out here you've been my brother my whole
life some people you know we make soup
and then we throw each other over each
other's shoulders you go [__] you Logan
but all right thanks for having me yeah
bro thank you for having me let's go
anybody [__] you suck it [__] Mom I
love you but Dad Yo cool too thanks for
coming out and also turkey beef soup
[Laughter]
oh he came back
oh [__] yeah
what is he saying George oh my God
oh my God
oh wow he's he's pretty much what I said
it's the man with the ties yeah it's a
sad bow tie he does look sad yes bow tie
looks even when he's smiling he's
breathed on him that was weird
[Laughter]
like all right man all right yeah
and now he's left alone
he's like looking at nothing
keep it open right yeah
dude they're not talking to me yeah yeah
yeah
well what am I gonna do
that long
we're here to talk about and commentate
the fight but it's more fun commentate
the commentators yeah
like he's trying to get a word yeah wait
what's going on hello
[Laughter]
nobody's gonna talk to me nobody's gonna
you're not teeing up anything for smile
faded look the smile faded now oh it's
like oh now uncle Buffer's getting in
the ring it's go time boys oh yeah he
said I'm never doing this again
yeah I don't think he's coming back the
truth
does this have big fight energy
do you think this feels like a big fight
I can tell without sound yeah
it's hard to tell us roasting the
commentators it doesn't I mean locally
it probably does do you sense is anybody
on other people's social media are
people talking about this
is this have Jake has a big phone you
know I know but just general this is
probably the biggest fight of the
weekend for sure yeah I mean it's a huge
fight again but what I'm saying is
there's like a lot of fights this
weekend but this one what I'm saying
Bellator UFC yeah the whale came out but
it's not prime time it's not Prime Time
in America prime time and when a fight
is prime time in America you see more
this is Sunday morning they had to do
this in Saudi Arabia so that's why the
time Church no I get it but I don't
remember the energy of being big time it
would have been way bigger if it was a
seven o'clock yes yeah our time yeah but
outside of that if you just look at
Twitter are people talking about I'm
sure yeah like it has to be trending
because what else would they be talking
about there's nothing going on Sunday
morning and there's no Sports there's no
NFL it's Sunday morning
Jesus yes that's what they could be
doing yes is Jesus trending no who's
doing better Jesus or Jake the prom
child I can figure that out but oh he's
back
and I turn this back to the other guy
but the guy on the left looks like he
just wants to why are you letting him
talk
yep it's go time boys oh no he went
right over to the left here we go and
they're out this is outside ten point
bus system no three notches outside yeah
there was a result fifth round Fighters
cannot be Saved by the Bell unless you
Mark Paul Gossler only referee can stop
the fight instant replay is available
Havana Brown
yeah just thrown in prison out there
oh there it looks bigger there doesn't
look like a lot though yeah let's get
him out
that's what I'm thinking let's make less
than ten thousand yeah yeah maybe yeah
oh three or five maybe
those Graphics I expect more from Saudi
Arabia yeah it looks like a light bright
yeah you know what that is
it's been like three hours yeah you've
gotten two of our references I know Ryan
I'll give you ten thousand Dollars theme
song
turn on the magic of colored lights
what that says
what is a fighter a person with the will
courage determination and ability or
just it's just left a person who can
read faster than me
I'll tell you what I don't need is this
right now let's just just get Michael
Buffer announce it let's roll Mike Tyson
what's he saying Adam well you gotta
trust yourself and fight like a fighter
you know if you live it you know make
you hungry but you know don't be full
I wonder if there's any like narration
over this Montage 100
what you think it's just silent do you
think it just could be just video
Tommy Fury
his brother
you think he beats usick yeah you do
yeah I think he beats every heavyweight
he's getting tough mama jama he's tough
but
Tyson Fury is tough and big and skilled
yeah he's getting skilled as a
[__] can go forward backwards
whatever you want
I just don't see it in Tommy man I could
be completely off on this but I just
don't see it I feel like Jake has he
[__] works hard doesn't he yes
yes Tommy has
bet like if he fights like how I've seen
him maybe right in the past it might be
a somewhat competitive but the last
fight was just so awful that I don't
even know what to say yeah I know
how much training in between uh uh
fights do you think is like required to
at least you're saying yeah yeah uh
maybe three four times a week gotcha
okay but most people don't so they hop
in eight week camp they don't do
anything though I always run and try to
stay in shape yeah do something every
day right but you always punching stuff
you you break down your joints and stuff
you know it's not good to always you
know be pounding it's like a pitcher
wouldn't pitch all year round right yeah
Adam no sips what's that no sips
no sips you're not drinking
no I mean I'll take a little shot I
guess
I want to book this NBC drama man oh
here we go diamond out Bambi Bambi see
it's like princess yeah see he's going
for that kind of vibe yeah he looks
nervous does he yeah that was a nervous
smile right there yeah
yeah he does it doesn't look um
but he hasn't been in big fights like
Jake has either like every fight Jake's
been in has been this massive and he's
got to live up to his family oh he
doesn't have to your brother's Tyson
Fury
your mom's mom is taking bets that you
don't want to take oh yeah so they're
not the whole person so Tyson fear and
Tommy Fury they have the same dad but
different moms okay that's why he's so
tan
and just like looks the opposite yeah
they yeah he's a handsome bastard and he
works on his eyebrows too you see
it's like waxed that's not a good
I think he's just he just had a kid he
just had a daughter oh is her name Bambi
that's his son Bambi I think so no no no
no no that's a dedication for you Bambi
with a butterfly for his new son maybe
that's a nickname
it wasn't her daughter well
Bambi is the news
her name's Bambi
you had it right you really thought for
a minute that his son this is my boy
Bambi I've heard weirder names for
people yeah they want him to get bullied
and grow up tough oh you're right Bambi
Bambi Fury the gypsies hey that's Bambi
fear there
[Laughter]
yeah he's never had a big fight like
this he looks nervous he looks terrified
see that's not he definitely not used to
the big lights right no it's his first
time man he looks uncomfortable leaving
with the camera he looks like a deer and
headlights yeah Jake's got an advantage
because Jake's like resting [__] face
is actually like a Mean Mug right and
being in front of his camera Jake had a
camera since he's four yeah that's right
and been in front of big crowds look at
the difference well this is still Bambi
it's a long walk it's a long walk
no we get it dude
right so I want my robe to be uh White
Silk but a lot of butterflies at the
bottom butterfly right after Bambi
I wonder who the audience is going for
I wonder if it's a pro Jake audience or
Pro Tommy audience I bet you it'll be
pro-jake and I'll tell you why because
they love bringing things to Dubai he
brought it there yeah you're right he
brought it there yeah it's his promotion
yeah
he's the one that's supporting and he's
saying you saw when he's going I'm going
to give to the audience yeah
what if Tyson's like please don't lose
this [__] Disney kid where's his dad
which one's his dad I think they had a
good approach this time to the fight
like uh you know I I think they'll be
able to take it better yeah if Tommy
loses because they were all buddy buddy
with each other yeah you know yeah if
Tommy gets knocked out he's gonna be
like he's a real fighter yeah he's the
real deal
I totally underestimate him I didn't
think he had it but yeah he does yeah
he's the real deal and then Tyson's like
you gotta give his kid his credit and
they're gonna do it but I feel like we
want to watch this fight but we kind of
all know what's gonna happen
you know that maybe got it yeah you
would think but you never know man
because there's that factor that yes
Mike Tyson yeah nobody thought that
would happen yeah
Michael Buffer in the flesh
you know it's so much money just say
let's get ready to rumble how much I
think he's back on a plane to him watch
the fight you talk about a one-hit
wonders yeah like that's crazy you think
you like to do it for a wedding video
you said like what oh that's that's
Bruce oh [__] Michael Buffer only does
let's get ready to rumble there's the
Michael Buble is that his dad he's paid
to say that is that his dad yeah no
that's a big gun was he a fighter
Gypsy like they would fight Gypsy
fighters
on the street oh really yeah like Fight
Club exactly but less we don't talk
about that yeah first rule of Fight Club
we're gonna talk about it that's okay
where's he from the father
uh well Tyson's from Manchester yeah
they're English but is the father from
England he's from tuam Ireland
Irish travelers hence why they're called
the Gypsy Kings
thank you George great band
that would be a good band name it is the
Gypsy Kings that's a real band yeah name
one song
I don't know the words that's from the
movie
um sing there you go
where the pigs dancing in the grocery
store
wait what movie John Fury
and I was like wait Pig's dancing how
was that movie great he's uh the zoo
does a American Idol yes great Matthew
McConaughey he's the main voice of the
koala what if we never watched the fight
we just broke down my whole [__]
thing
who else is doing it what other animals
wow this is gorilla who's fantastic
suit doesn't fit that's okay these guys
are well be people want to steal that
little printed
name
that's been laminated he's guarding the
lamination you stand outside because
people want that guy's nervous he looks
like Tommy Fury yeah he's nervous
like the camera's on me right now
hey Bigfoot out of the shot
the Dad what's up dude what's going on
here oh no don't come out and don't come
out in a weird suit
can't get it on over his clothes hold up
yeah hey guys yeah like nobody thought
about the gloves he's off [__] is it all
lit up
is that a Jersey from the Rocks Football
League
it's probably the most normal [__] we've
seen tonight well it does have lights
it's a bedazzled windbreaker
did you see his shorts when he had the
logo on it that had the the computer
graphics on it nuts yeah that was sick
nuts
shorts is he wearing though
I don't know see I'm getting nervous for
him right now there's no there's none of
that going I mean is it Logan carrying
his prime
is he oh yeah that's a huge huge
promotion for him right yeah
I like how he does do two different
colored gloves me too
look at the difference in this face and
the his his oh one thousand percent
difference
he looks like he's ready to kill yeah
I'd say Tommy has better fundamentals
because he grew up boxing in the amateur
scene but Jake just has that power I
just think his but there's more
confidence he's also got a crazy look to
him just like in his you know like when
Jake fights and he throws he has some
like demons man you know like Tommy does
it
I saw an interview them talking about
their upbringing they had a really rough
upbringing the pause yeah
so if Jake wins he's done what and if
Tommy Lindsay's done what Jake has
finally beat a boxer sort of right yeah
who's yeah yeah booze uh George is
saying Jake's getting booze what did uh
come into his room afterwards no booze
right now as he's walking out as he's
walking out I mean that's Jake though
you love to hate him right that's his
thing yeah but think about how much
money he makes no but that audience we
were saying who are they for do you
think they're just having fun by booing
him I think it's the thing to do it's
like yeah it's like the thing to do you
want to be that right like you don't
want to be the one [__] cheering for
Jake Paul
not yet at least not yet yeah right he
wins this one and then he beats Nate
then it's gonna change for him I think
like remember people like hated Bieber
then he just came with the slappers
Non-Stop
definitely a difference in walk out in
their mannerisms
you can tell Jake takes it serious
he is he's been in big moments too so
this is nothing new I'm thinking when
you work this hard like you you're going
through camp and you're doing all this
work and then it comes to the down to
this even if it's 12 rounds right you
know it's down to this 15 minutes 36
minutes 36 minutes
that's an amazing Pinnacle to kind of
fight for yeah it's like the Super Bowl
every time you go in
if this is it yeah how do you feel when
you're making this walk when you're
doing this walk does this are you aware
of the room or you're just in your own
mind I'm aware I'm aware
they're still booing them Georgie
no quiet well that's not good either
no they've gotten completely silent
not his brother look he's carrying his
prime that's just always promoting
deji
a lot of phones out
if you have so much money there that's
why they brought like everyone Tyson
Deontay
oh that's weird what do they say to each
other can you hear them no
that's weird
unless they're talking [__] they're not
weird they were talking [__] did you see
the did you see the land yeah yeah they
were oh yeah
there's I feel like there's actual Bad
Blood you know sometimes guys just hype
it up yeah
I think he's pissed that he canceled so
many times yes
three times yeah it cost him a lot of
money
so remember one was in New York and all
the promotion dollars are like a week up
the Wednesday before the fight is that
why they did Tyrone Willy too I think so
yes yep and they had an even replacement
for Tommy Fury uh and Mike Perry just in
case Tommy for whatever reason didn't
show didn't want to fight they had a
backup
Tommy's 23. he's young man could have
swore he was older me too
23. a lot of people think Tommy's bigger
too and he's not I'm older than Tommy
Fury damn that's nuts yeah he's 23. what
the hell
I was 23 for like a year what happened
huh well that's kind of short though
for I don't think so for each person
Howie what were we doing at 23 years old
that's when I that at 23 years old it
was the first time I went on stage
from a deer from Adair at 23 years old
April 19 1977. for a year that's cool I
got dared to get up on stage at a comedy
club now
I'm sitting with a
four guys watching a fight I can't hear
life takes you down strange paths
is that you were here yes oh yes
what do you mean you why is that amazing
that at one point in my life I had hair
because I've only ever seen people you
thought it was born like this like a
newborn
that guy yeah it's hard to picture him
like no way wow look at that shot yeah
Hall and Oates bring that back
I'm sure Theo's got some extra mullet
wigs yeah I had a mullet before mullets
were happening we're Ohio I feel like
Canadians and mullets go peanut butter
jelly yeah that's what you guys think
about it yeah Gretzky had one hell yeah
you got Logan lift up the prime
I didn't mind the prime have you tried
I'm surprised they haven't asked you for
sponsorship yet well I'm a Gatorade so
yeah okay
you did that he never heard of him he
announced it on he did the podcast at my
place yeah and him and what's the guys
KSI yeah we're at my place doing the
video for them oh that's right
Pacquiao announced his last fight at my
place too on the Hologram no Pacquiao
was in the Philippines so he has this
crazy hologram thing where Pacquiao
do you live here in the yeah right here
yeah me too well me too you should come
to the office on time yeah so that he
announced this fight he was in the he
was no he was in Korea oh wow and his
opponent was Korean who was here in Van
Nuys and he announced live on the
Hologram but they can see each other
it's crazy his technology is nuts have
you guys gotten into a place yet where
you can do it for shows still yeah yeah
no I did it at JFL yeah we're going to
do it in in London at the O2
congratulations you should you could
tour like this please without going
someplace okay I think you're just gonna
just testing it out just testing it yeah
and they can see each other yeah you can
see it in real time yeah that's in my
office see look he's standing there they
can see each other and there and uh
there was 200 people in my in the
warehouse from like AP all the uh the
Press yeah the announcing and he's
looking at they're looking at each other
in real time with no latency
yeah
but that guy he's in Korea and this
Korean is in Van Nuys it's so weird
how to go down now come on boys get in
there there's the diarrhea belt diarrhea
belt the one and only wow
wow who would imagine that one day
somebody would be fighting for diarrhea
Tommy does look good not getting hit
there his movement
you know what he looks like granny looks
like a boxer right now which Jake hasn't
faced yeah
but they don't have that
he doesn't have that much more he's got
eight fights right eight fights yeah yes
to six yeah but he has a lot more
amateur okay so they say I don't see any
record of it but as you know where he's
grown up with you know
stressful and he's not even close to it
right do one round I think no wait
what'd you say Howie he's not close to
the none of his brother no no his
brother's six eight yeah
if he was the size of his brother he
would be heavily you know you say they
have different mothers yeah so the uh
his brother's mother was probably huge
oh such a good question don't you don't
they check in boxing they don't uh you
have to take this one right you have to
be enrolled in uh
testing so if you don't they pretty much
don't test you they don't well if you're
gonna go to the Olympics they do yeah
but otherwise they don't not really I
mean don't do it here and there but it's
like consistent have you ever been
tested yeah I'm on uh I'm enrolled in
Nevada
so they come randomly so a lot of fight
before the fights to say Hey you gotta
enroll in usada like he's saying uh Bata
testing and some Fighters like no
were you tested in the UFC yeah it is
annoying though like they'll come out of
nowhere you'll be doing something and
say oh we're coming usada is very strict
it's unannounced if you go on vacation
you have to give them your location
they'll show up on your vacation George
more booze unless your name's Conor
McGregor
more booze
for Lo uh for Jake you want some more
booze I know I'm saying are they you
want more booze get them booze
yeah so Furious cheered and Jake Paul's
skin but do you think they're just
playing a game yeah the audience it's
the thing to do yeah you want the bad
guys there's a heel right yeah
therein lies a little bit of the WWE Yes
you know of course
but they love that
you should have Michael B Jordan in this
corner let's promote uh creep three it's
a great idea right promo Corner yeah
they should always be a guy like that
yeah
he's here now he's got game face let's
go I like how Jake's here didn't give a
[__] he's focused on fighting Tommy's
worried about his looks here we go
Jake and four
Jake under four I should say Jake wait
to hear my prediction
[Music]
there we go
they're going okay go ahead and zoom in
for us camera man oh
a little more aggressive I like the fast
start
that's not like Thomas whoa
Tommy's like to stick on the outside he
came in hot remember his but yeah and
Jake's not well against Anderson go for
it he looks like he's a little shocked
because uh Jake is not good going back
no Jake does really well going forward
whoa
see that's what boxers are good at
they're good at the tying up tying up
yeah frustrating yeah
and fury is good at that the older
brother
very good very good whoa we just got him
again
whoa whoa whoa oh Jake Jake's initiating
these hugs no rough start for Jake uh
it's Tommy closing the distance there
which usually he sits on the outside so
this is interesting Jake looks like I'm
sure his brother and his dad has
something to do with him these guys
coming out this hot yeah just energy
wise Tommy is uh
a couple steps ahead it feels like hey
ref get the [__] out of the way I know
like dude relax
there shouldn't be a I don't like that I
mean look damn [__] dude
whose footwork is better right I'm gonna
land the right hand uh Tommy Tommy right
now Tommy's good with his jab too
look his hair doesn't even mess I know
it's like a Lego piece he's a Greek god
yeah I'm assuming Jake thoughts
he does doesn't he yeah he does I don't
think Jake was expecting this pace Jake
is gonna try to line that right yeah all
Jake needs is one oh [__] oh oh but he's
getting I want to see what happens when
when Fury gets here
oh if that even comes to happen
yeah wow
right now this is
so surprising Tommy doesn't look tired
no Tommy looks great I was tired a
minute in oh see what happens yeah
time but one time
it's only ways you can get respect if he
lands a good one to keep it sometimes
yeah that was a great shot and his cheek
is red too
their body languages are so different
right now
Jake looks like he's just trying to land
one yeah he doesn't look like he's gonna
be a problem
see I don't like Tommy Tommy had the
right idea going forward there he got
caught with that shot but yeah he
shouldn't throw you off no he should
keep doing it because it threw Jake off
if you're gonna sit on the outside and
just let Jake Land one ooh Jake on the
body he's trying to set that up
go down then go up
anybody else distracted my tongue his
body [__] stupid right
no carbs no oh my God he was fast
trying to slip and times that right now
whoa yeah
he's fast yeah he is Tommy has a lot oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa [__] that was almost
it oh man Tommy really that's the round
right 100 yeah
you're like yeah
wow
interesting
Tommy's walking in though he got to be
careful leaning in with that jab yes
that overhand right that's how he got it
yeah put you to sleep if you if you only
thinking about the offense on that
double Jab
oh yeah dude
man about one there in that whole combo
I gotta go I love you guys oh see you
later
you're the best Brothers hilarious dude
yeah you're the best man if uh new
prediction if Tommy does it in three
I'll take everybody to lowers okay oh
nice okay now your Steakhouse
oh it's my boy Lowry he just makes uh
meatballs and mac and cheese no I'm in
dude
thanks guys love you but he kind of
blocked it a little bit he didn't get
the full force of
a lot of more faints but let's see if he
corrects himself they're still feeling
each other out yeah Jake's a little
sporadic yeah wait I don't feel like
he's moving this is where experience
comes into play here Jake doesn't have
the experience so he keeps jamming
himself
yeah I haven't seen backing up I haven't
seen Jake fight like this really
I think this is the the most prominent
boxer he has fought in that job by a lot
yeah I agree that job he looks like a
boxer in the ring his movement is
fantastic so far his Jabs really doesn't
have any movement he's just he's just
trying to walk him down and he's not
cutting them off he's loading up he
looks panicked a little bit kind of
stiff yes
time is very fluid good job good
footwork not let him pin them down
I would sign that contract now if I was
him double or nothing
now he's doing it oh [__] let's get
moved oh
yeah man he's just winging there
whoa he keeps taking it in the face
great job
yo Tommy's on it I don't think Tommy's
focused Jake doesn't have really good
defense and Jake doesn't have any
defense no his defense is looking
suspect right now
there that was defense
the last right hand huh
but you still got that feeling that
Jacob 100 all it takes is one
he's waiting for it he's looking for it
but I feel like he's so focused on
looking for that one in that he's not
he's not really setting it up he's not
playing the game that guy's well he's
waiting for that he's gonna get the [__]
kicked out yes that's what's going on
he's teeing off he's just looking for
the one he's just playing the points
game right now see that's the shot but
he missed so who's playing the points
game Fury Fury yeah yeah fuse lightning
yeah it is and that's it that's the shot
he's looking for every time
he's got this one too Fury yeah
clear
good job there's no way this is going 12
rounds
uh eight eight
well am I not right is there no way it's
going 12 rounds you're correct yes
um
yeah Jake's needs to calm down a little
bit he's a little sloppy
and he's not setting any shots up it
does look like a boxer fighting a
non-boxer it's really clear I agree
and that's where the criticism is going
to come from yeah yeah
Jake's down two rounds
easy yes
he also looks a little messed up he
doesn't look like he's in good shape two
rounds in time fight he does look a
little different than
he looked more focused in better shape
when he fought Anderson yeah
maybe maybe Tommy but he thought Tom was
gonna walk in the park and Tommy can
fight maybe I would imagine yeah yeah
that last fight he didn't no not at all
Tommy's never looked but he's never as
you just said he's never fought a boxer
mm-hmm
this is Tommy's sport not Jake's Jake's
learning it Jake's good for what he's
done 100.
well I grazed him grazed him but didn't
even mess his hair
his hair doesn't move so your dad is
standing yeah they don't the hair piece
doesn't move even look perfect perfect
it's just a commercial for his hair yeah
even when you get hit yeah it stays for
hairspray if Tommy were to win I wonder
where he goes from hair
cause he's still he's still I don't
think he'll get the same no respect as
Jake would get no they're like yeah you
beat a YouTuber man you know yeah or a
Disney kid
oh they're throwing them now Tommy needs
to get back to that to that jab and not
play this game with him though yeah
you're playing the dangerous yes
because I still have that feeling that
Jacob me too crack him yeah Tommy needs
to be on the ball here he needs to not
take no real risk just kind of yeah man
keep doing what you're doing just take
the jab move your foot
good job
he's going to the body getting more
aggressive
he's frustrating right yeah he's trying
to
so all right let me be a little bit more
aggressive let me throw more punches but
in Reading how he was preparing for this
he said he wants to be able to change
his game plan mid game as you called it
improv I'm just gonna have to
yeah
he knocked him down late in the round so
it's there
but he didn't look this tired against
the ocean no no he looked tired at the
end of the first yeah he did in this
fight
that job's a real issue for me I don't
really know how to deal with it finally
whoa and he has no remember in the end
of the fight he's throwing faints and
right yeah there's no faint
he's just setting up that right hand
but this this round is pretty even in my
mind so far yeah I agree
I like Jake's new approach a little bit
more aggress but Tommy's also not going
forward as much either
he's tiring himself out maybe
Jake is weighing them
now remember too Tommy's hasn't gone
past five rounds so that sixth seventh
eighth round maybe that's what Jake's
banking on we haven't talked about this
do you think they they'll give it a
tummy even though oh that's a good point
that the judges oof
oh good check hook great hook
I mean I'll be curious if Tommy's still
focused in the fifth sixth seventh and
eighth because he takes his eye off the
prize he's gonna get knocked out
yeah early on you know
whoa
that's all he's looking for huh
oh
put his head into him
that was a Tyson move yeah like a
Hollywood
they're making that rough work tonight
this was a good competitive round right
yeah
Tommy's off the ball a little bit Yeah
you see Tommy's looking tired now
I mean that's why I'm gonna see where
Tom's at his time down anymore well he
came in hot
kinda
stepped on the gas a little early whoa
yeah good job Jake's coming back I like
this
okay it's turned into a fight
and
it's round
that's good that was a good defense if
I'm Tommy next round I'll come in I'm
coming more Adam me too and I'm just
watching for the right hand yeah once I
come in I'm just gonna keep my guard up
yep left hand up once I block it once
then I'm working them yep or fake them
wait for the right if it don't come then
then you have to mix it up though you
just gotta know what what the guy's
trying to do he's obviously trying to
load up that right hand so just wait for
it and keep coming out
but if I'm Jake Jake what's his brother
saying what's his brother saying
probably pushing Pride saying the last
to come back a winner come back under
Shield
come back a winner or what come back
like go out go out don't play it safe
yeah Jake needs to mix it up or not just
look for the right hand set up with the
hook his Hooks Landing
he's not throwing combinations either
everything's one one and out or one and
grabbing Jake yes yes he needs to mix it
up more common that's what he's known
for there's that one shot right here oh
my God
he keeps swinging and shooting it
missing
a lot to the body whoa look how fast he
is he did those pretty clearly
oh Tommy looks phenomenal right now
oh
sloppy Tommy too huh yeah the family
name
all this stuff is oh my God and it's a
YouTuber you know it's not a boxer yet
this could make him a boxer
yep that was a good move he stuffed it
that was smart
Jake no uh he stuffed that right hand
that Jake was loaded up on he smothered
Jake's shot by going into him
whoa whoa oh
that one rocked him a little bit Jake
had to do his little step
s pummeled
yeah I could see it three nothing for
Tommy so far
this one is really clear yes he's
getting he's getting worked oh no yeah
he is
the only way Jake's gonna be able to
pull this out is to land that one and
knock him out and he's nowhere unless
the urgency now though that he could do
it yes
I'm just I mean Jake's team has to bank
on Tommy getting tired in this fifth
yeah
Tommy's on it man Tommy hasn't been past
five you said no no sir
but Jake looks pretty tired yeah he also
hasn't taken this many shots no and he
hasn't had much success either so I
don't [__] with your mental game this is
the most shots I've seen Jake take yes
and not have much success at all
whoa
oh oh oh no no no Tommy you gotta stay
on it buddy
he did land there oh [__]
closing the round good if you're a Jake
Paul fan
oh for those just listening is the
fourth round and they're 24 seconds left
Jake's ending strong
yeah Jake is the aggressor now he was
backing up for the first three yeah
it's probably the most success things
change would you give this to would you
give this to Jake no no
no not for one shot no oh
yeah I heard a point no you can't take a
point off the first one though it's just
gonna give him a warning
uh I'd probably say Jake's down four
rounds he better he better start winning
because Tommy Tommy was doing so good up
until that point it was like one shot
Tommy dominated probably two minutes and
30 seconds that round
whoa look at that
we're watching the uh replays of boo
he's just pummeling his face after it
Jake's not Landing anything me too he
did it right here this is the leftover
oh that one shot that's a good shot oh
that oh that messed him up a little bit
his eyes were out boom
Boop
still didn't win him around no
but that was a great show yeah really
good but all it takes is that one shot
to knock them down and Jake has the bank
on that he's down four rounds of zero
I'd say
he needs to keep down the left side he
looks now he he looks like he's got a
second win Jake doesn't he
he needs to let go that left more
because that's what's working and this
is where he's banking on maybe Tommy
getting tired here this is his this is
Tommy hasn't gotten around past let me
keep that hand down a lot
he looks a lot better it's like he woke
up in the fifth
oh yeah I wonder if the game plan well
it didn't look like it was one of the
game plans to start applying pressure
late because Tommy hasn't been in late
rounds have you ever had second wins oh
yeah yeah yeah this state this deep into
a yeah
it's weird like sometimes it just takes
a while to warm up has that happened to
you Ryan where and like sticks around
like man now now I'm good to go took a
while to warm up
yeah you get past that tire station yeah
and then it just it just happens
again like all this hugging how they're
like the distance control that's how you
know that there's not a lot of
experience like you won't see that in
Ryan's fight against tank yeah whoa you
don't hold the ocean no you just hit him
yep he has footwork's too good oh good
job by Jakey there
oh whoa Fury just slipped it hit him oh
he's not reading
the that's the thing that he really
needs to know
interesting fight nonetheless oh one
point for Jake is there a point really
one point
oh my God why why
because he hit the back of the head
they're both getting points taken away
are they oh [__] back in the head Fury
hit him in back of the head
that's weird because fear hit him
directly are they is it only Jake or
only Jake oh that's that's bad that's
bad for this guy that screws Jake
because he's down four rounds already
Jay got to go For Broke now oh
Jake's on it now
oh my God he's coming dude
come on Lee
all right Jake get him come on Jakey I
see a little fear and Fury's eyes now
Maybe not
maybe not
let go that left again keep using that
left there you go Jake
boy that point deduction is massive
especially this point for in the fight
Maybe
I think this is going to end this is
going to end in a knockout
you think yes
Jake right yes interesting Jake will
knock the other guy out yes you think
what are you calling right I could see
that honestly I could see it on the left
I could see you've gain days yeah the
left's the only thing that's really
great Listen by points Fury's got this
100 can Fury make it 12 a 10-8 rounds
nah
you know the conspiracy series will say
it's not part of the script yeah
Tommy's [__] up the script right now
well if you want to believe in
conspiracies which I don't believe in
it's better for the it's better it's
better for the sport to have Jake win
right 100 Howie
yeah because the yeah I'd be curious how
they're feeling too you're not gonna get
to see another Fury fight after he beat
a YouTuber no
that's so true yeah like how many people
would pay for the rematch of this
not many
no that was the best best shot of the
night
slip yep boom
I think he's landed to your point Ryan
that's the shot that uh that Tommy keeps
missing so
great shirt
cool fish shirt
I think he has Tanked
okay so here we are Fury going into
round six yeah sixth round he's never
gone six rounds Fury's up five to
nothing yeah and it now but this is
gonna end in a knockout now Jake has to
get a knockout he will
watch look he comes out aggressive
this round if your time is just gonna be
smart you're gonna be defensive yeah
you're not gonna take too many chances
I won't even be thinking about punching
right now but guys just bomb rushing me
just cut your defense you get to fight
one if you see the shot nobody expects
you to win by knockout either
stay focused
I mean no oh good uppercut no faints
from Jake he needs Whoa man he needs
fans
Jake looks more messed up than he's ever
looked up than he's ever looked before
that was a long hold there oh
Fury landed it cut by Fury yeah he found
that shot that's the shot that Jake's
gonna be susceptible all night probably
or so you find something like that and
then you got to keep going through it
until they change it up
because they probably don't even know
why they got hit or you don't think he
he changes his defense he got through
and Jake probably hasn't been hit like
that before in a real fight right yeah
yeah you know why he got hit with that
see how he keeps doing it every time so
all time he could have kept doing this
every time it comes in same shot you can
do it again oh she's going to do it well
yeah because he's lowering his head yeah
every time he comes in yeah oh my gosh
his head just stays low it's never up
and Jake just keeps initiating the a lot
of boxers in the beginning stages they
do that though yes they throw and then
they'll cover up like that because out
of fear like not knowing where to do
what spacing they're at he just landed
Jake
Jake landed as
objective yes
the Africa oh my God
it's where do you want to go back to it
after you had success
the ref's like we just [__] hold each
other I know get out of here bro nobody
wants to see you you didn't come to
watch them he's eating up the clock too
that left foot's there for Jake too
yeah that's yeah all day uppercut for
Tommy well the only thing Jake can do is
a knockout because there's no way he's
got it's about five for him to win on
the car he's got five rounds
bro this rep needs to stop bro
yeah you shouldn't be a factor in this
fight man
oh
you can't take a point for that though
silly
do you want to fight
is too much
the ref might be like a purist you know
he hates this stuff
like a clinch is gonna happen bro
he's just yelling at Jake though
oh good check hook
use your [__] faints Jake
whoa
he's getting dicey for Jakey yeah yeah
the only out that Jake has is a knockout
yep oh yeah even if he wins the next two
that's impossible yeah
he can knock him down get a 10-8 round
he still won't win
that's the one that's there good timing
great time
it doesn't seem to affect him no Jake
has a good chance
you took that good one from uh boom whoa
flush too
that angle with the camera
yeah that's freaking amazing
he keeps rocking him with that hood
they gotta eat how in the [__] do they
have it even I don't know who's calling
that and what who is Sean Sean Mendes
[Laughter]
there's no way it's not even listen I
I'm rooting for Jake I bet money he is
not winning this this is not an even
fight not even close
to give Jake the second and third round
that's insane or the third round because
third round yeah that was the one where
you're like oh this is this is
definitely a one-sided fight
oh man the amount of [__] Jake's gonna
give the judges give it to him oh I know
it might be worse than that yeah I don't
think he cares
oh that right hand is not has not landed
tonight
you can tell they trained the right hand
didn't try and count on his left yeah
what about the left don't worry about it
just take it on the chin yeah don't
worry about the left he barely throws it
so there
I'll tell you right now Nate Diaz is
watching us licking this [__] chops
well
yeah maybe I just think that I don't
know Tommy's boxing good yeah you know
what I mean yeah
I don't know if Nate can box it but I
don't know how Nate fights NATO volume
fighter so he's like no no he just comes
he's constantly forward which could be
an issue for Jake
like bro you could initiate a little
clinch like that or you can't have a
problem with that yeah this ref is just
he's a purist and does it like these two
are oh my God
is more in the fight Than Jake which is
terrible what the hell
are they talking about the ref being in
there too much
uh they mentioned that it's a wrestling
match a little bit
what not complaining about the rest
they're clinching so much because
they're both tired there's no footwork
so they're just rush into each other
there's not enough experience huh from
both of them yeah from both of them
I just don't think Tommy likes fighting
in the inside
no he doesn't like to get dirty that's
why he always goes for the hole uh-huh
and that's where Jake's Powers at
you know
oh
oh wow
I don't see him in any world you give
that round to Jake
who knows what how sean Mendes is
scoring this
judge what if it's just Shawn Mendes oh
actually it's Sean Porter that's who it
is oh good call
oh he has a cut
who has the cake
Jake Fury not over his eyebrow
surprised if it when it's not here uh
headbutt see
is that is that his hair his hair kind
of finally got [__] up Howie his tears
out of his hair is finally gone it's
gone down his brother look his brother
thinks he's losing he goes damn oh yeah
oh yeah bad
games natural fuel uh Jake I think for
the last round hurray
but I mean seeing that scorecard they
might just give it
but yeah but who knows I have no clue
you don't want to go into the judges in
[__] Saudi Arabia oh are they like
are they sanctioned judges are they
Saudi Arabian judges are they Jake
Paul's uncles right no no because it's
his promotion awesome like remember when
Canelo fought Triple G clear as day
Canelo lost that fight first the first
one and they give Triple G like how in
the world to come up with that they go
it's a Golden Boy promotion
boom
as much as they're clinching that's what
I suspect it was a headbutt
is this the last round yeah
the ref's like all right guys I'm
exhausted let's keep it clean
yeah see I'm sick of fighting
oh
man that right so far off for Jake
oh [__] there you go Tommy
whoa Jesus Christ Jake
oh
he's saying he slipped his feet got
crossed we'll have to see the replay
they're doing whatever it takes to get
Jake to win here by the way
yeah makes sense yes it's better for
the sport and the promotion for money
I'd say right
this would have been great for like a 10
round though yeah I agree
who decides on how many rounds why is it
eight they agreed probably conditioning
what are they like I could do eight
could they go 12 if they want to run at
their level yeah
your next fight how many rounds
yeah have you gone 12 once
Jake trying with that left hook
so if you give that knockdown wouldn't
make it 10-8 because when the crazy
knock down
but it's the most significant thing that
happened in the fight yeah yo man so
that that cost that would tell me the
fight oh my God
on Shawn Mendes yes
yes
even if he tripped yeah because they
counted as a knockdown for the rest oh
whoa now you want to throw uppercuts one
minute left now I'm saying he's like man
this uppercut's Landing I know
Tyson Furious shadow box in the back oh
oh that was a hard
oh
this is a good fight yeah better than I
thought me too
not as one-sided as I thought not even
close
oh my right hand
started trade with it yeah
great yeah Tommy don't start trading now
bro
we've gone all this way boxing yeah I
know you want to play this phone booth
30 seconds left they're both tired 30
seconds left and then my prediction
[Laughter]
boy if someone could get a knock down
here oh that uppercut there you go it's
so sad he just found out 40 seconds to
fight that though because it's like dude
from the first round this thing's over
oh now I figured it out
see changes
how many seconds left I'm saying I'm
gonna let go Jake look at the ref
the ref
oh wow they're really tired it's over
there right it's over yeah it's over
so who are they gonna give it to for
sure you think Jake for sure because the
judging or just because the lockdown
well the knockdown if we're scoring it
right I I think I gave Jake I don't know
if I gave Jake a round other than the
knockdown well but they were even you
knew they were even well shot from
Sean's thing but I personally think that
Fury was winning the rankings right me
too I thought Fury
I thought Fury is up on the cards and I
thought the only way Jake could win is
by a knock knockout
I thought Tommy for the first six sailed
to it I'll tell you something regardless
even if Tommy oh he didn't trip no no
that's definitely uh you know but it was
it didn't look like he's concussed
because look he lost his balance yeah
that's a lockdown yeah squared off boom
I'll tell you something even if Fury
wins I don't think this is bad for Jake
because he held his own the whole time
and I would see a rematch yeah I could
see a rematch yeah
one more rounds I do too but this is not
a an embarrassing loss no no no no no
Jake did his thing for sure
I think also it pumps the brakes a
little bit because him knocking out
these guys and we did to Anderson who's
older you know everyone's like we want
to see him fight Canelo and Ryan Garcia
it's like all right let's chill you know
he only has six fights seven yeah boom
and for only having seven fights the
guy's pretty [__] good
at this magnitude you know it's got to
hang your even if you lose this one
still the only some fights man but he's
not losing badly if he does lose this
one
I I would be willing to bet for Jake
it's a little bit of a reality check
like slow your roll let's fight the MMA
guys let's not you know keep [__]
with these real boxers
I don't know why you would either
because you know his lowest uh
Pay-Per-View fight Of All Times National
Silva which is his toughest fight ever
was it yeah so it's like dude people are
tuned in when you fight lesser no lesser
Fighters keep making the money and doing
your thing
are they reading out the scorecards now
not yet
do you think the gypsies are gonna Riot
and [__] storm that place as the
capital if they go with Jake Paul
they're calling Championship aren't they
in their corner
Jake has the the energy like you didn't
win
I don't know salty there yeah I thought
it'd be a lot cooler to each other
we can't hear them
it's friendly banter okay it's friendly
they're just saying good job yeah
well Tom gets way more respect now right
after looking at all his other fights
does he he look like [__] seriously why
would he get more research when you look
at his record the the people he fought
it was really like yeah I had no respect
read it out live to us Georgie
wow whoa
76-73 for Fury probably how I had a
little bit yeah
there you go
I did not think they were going to give
it to him
it's good that they actually did though
right because yeah yeah that's I that's
fair yeah
but I don't think it marred
we said lose it and lose it all do you
think this lost at all for no no before
that was not this time before yeah he
did good you know yeah he fought a guy
that was more experienced than Jay for
sure he fought a boxer yeah for sure
don't cry Tommy but yeah I hear you yeah
yeah yeah he did not win the World
Championship you didn't be Canelo let's
wow
is the dad still talking [__]
most of the Two Dads oh they're being
cool
wow
it was a competitive fight it was a real
I I thought Tommy Fury won the fight for
sure and I'm Pro Jake and I thought well
he's crying look his hair he got the
diarrhea belt man his haircut
both of their hairs got messed up I
really no he came back Jay came in with
messy hair
yeah I wonder if they're going to talk
stuff to each other
well no cameras No cameras please
cameras he's crying why would he block
the camera first of all you're in the
ring fighting it's called pay-per-view
view
if you're just listening uh part of uh
Fury's team is putting their hands up
like don't shoot this don't we don't
want any of this on camera oh there they
go that's good
he said you can do anything you want
when you set your mind to it but be a
boxer I appreciate you doing this
laughs
and my mother respect great buildup
great fight yeah that's cool man that's
how it should be
yeah for Jake I think he's still good
the Nate Diaz fight's not going anywhere
he I think just play that game and make
all the money don't worry about getting
the validation from the boxing Community
but also I think there's a rematch here
100 it could be a remission yeah I'd
watch it
yeah I'll watch the rematch yeah it
wasn't I'll tell you what I won't do
break down the prelims
for five hours before like next time
we're just gonna come in an hour before
and I enjoy you guys but uh I'm uh kind
of tired of this dude I've never even
talked about my dad this long yeah I
don't I would imagine if you've been
watching the whole time you're an idiot
yeah I agree I'm just saying that I
agree fast forward just to the main
event yeah this is really this is insane
I if I could have clicked out of this I
would yeah I don't want to be here
I think that's it is that it I hope it's
it
well we don't have to do a live stream
of interviews do we Ron your fight is
April Devonte tank Davis April 22nd
come listen to you and we're gonna do a
tick tock right yeah so you guys gonna
dance I get some tour dates for you guys
uh next Friday one night two shows at
Brea Improv shopping friends Bray improv
and I'm in Oklahoma City bricks down
Comedy Club Oklahoma March 9th through
the 11th and then Tacoma Washington one
of my favorite spots Tacoma Comedy Club
March 23rd to the 25th all right love
you guys tickets for the UK tours on
sale pre-sale for June I'm in Glasgow
I'm in Dublin London Manchester I'm all
over Belfast Glasgow
I got a glass cow okay I'm a speech
opponent that would be cool all right uh
thickboy.com love you guys thanks for
tuning in Ryan Howie from for Adam Ray
love you guys thanks for tuning in stay
safe see ya bye